we live
corinne live c'est parti
[Musique]
cherchez l album ce que vous m'entendez
pas ce que ça marche
l eau vous pouvez me répondre dans le
chat pour voir si ça marche mieux
hier le bienvenu pour ce troisième live
au salon petit à petit
voilà voilà donc vous avez le sujet de
la première question du premier quiz
bonjour à tous et bienvenue donc le
premier cuisent sa porte sur voilà
imagine que d'une petite pièce à une
pièce suisses 2,5 france qui sait des
pièces assez grosse être visible à la
caméra et bomba imaginons que je la
lance comme ça et là ça tombe sur piles
et jeanne ans à nouveau sa tombe à
nouveau sur piles et je la lance à
nouveau et ça tombe à nouveau sur piles
et ainsi de suite dix fois de suite la
question c'est lorsque je lancerai une
onzième fois est-ce que 11e lancer la
pièce aura plus de chances de tomber
surface que sur piles il pour répondre à
cette question donc on va faire des
cuisses béziat comme à chaque fois dans
ses live donc vous allez sur la page
bit.ly sache s4 alive 3 culan avec des
tirs en bas des underscore
entre chacun électrique et vous devez
est tombé sur un google forme où on vous
demande de répondre je vous demande de
répondre entre 0 et 10 donc zéro c'est
exact absolument sûr que la réponse à
cette question est non dit si vous
n'êtes absolument sûr que la réponse à
cette question est oui
et si vous répondez 5 ben c'est que vous
êtes un état d'incertitude maximale si
vous répondez 6 à 7 c vous pencher
plutôt d'un côté occurrence du côté du
oui
sur les bancs des deux ou trois manches
et pas mal du côté du nom et pour voir
comment ce sera noté bon je
l'expliquerai ça après mais on va aller
voir directement sur le lien bit.ly
slash corse corbeil ce qui est
d'ailleurs pas un joueur frais que je
mette à jour un peu moins mais il y un
bit lit mais vous donne une idée en gros
bah si si vous êtes si vous penchez un
peu du bon côté même pas mal d'humour
ainsi beaucoup reproché de penché de mon
côté vous marquez déjà beaucoup de
points si vous penchez vous êtes
s'imaginent que la réponse soit oui et
vous êtes à huit ou neuf marques et déjà
c'est quoi exactement mais huit ou neuf
points sur 10 sont vous êtes déjà très
très très bonne cote en revanche si vous
dites oui tout neuf et que la réponse
vous dise et que la réponse est non dire
que si vous pensiez pas mal du mauvais
côté à ce moment là vous avez une énorme
pénalité et enfin ça va être dans les
rues dans les -30 ça fait très très mal
et du coup vaut mieux bien jugé sue de
son incertitude et si jamais ou trompait
souvent comme ça pas ça peut faire en
sorte que même si vous pensiez
régulièrement du bon côté
le fait de vous tromper à ce point ça
peut donner à des lieues des scores très
négatif en moyenne et malheureusement
sur les deux cuisses et sur les deux
lives précédent voyez un peu un débat
sur le premier
live pour savoir une question sur lequel
je me suis trompé mais ce qui est sûr le
deuxième live c'était assez nette que
vous aviez fini dans le négatif c'est à
dire moins bien que quelqu'un qui
répondrait à chaque fois le jeune je ne
sais absolument pas en moyenne donc pas
ton prenez le temps de bien juger votre
degré d'incertitude
ainsi si déjà on peut progresser en ces
termes ce sera déjà une victoire pour
moi j'aimerais dire parce que apprendre
à mieux raisonner de façon de béziers
mieux réfléchir en termes de priorité
c'est aussi ça c'est aussi être capable
de mesurer à quel point on est sûr de
soi je fais un blabla le temps que tout
le monde réfléchisse un peu à la
question est y répondre à la question
or bizarrement youtube me dit que vous
êtes 68 en ce moment ce qui ce qui est
bizarre parce qu'il est déjà 78
il dit je vois qu est-ce qui fait et pas
très à jour jeu
qu'a donc 84 réponse c'est bien ces
statistiques tutu souvent un manque que
quelques îles 10 d'entre vous qui avez
même le compteur est bloqué à 68,7
réactualiser la page youtube est en
train d'être d'être étiez vous avez 239e
assez c'est assez bizarre spiritueux
[Musique]
mise à jour 2 136 c'est mieux du coup on
peut peut-être atteindre les 100
réponses quand même sa première question
c'est plus dur souvent les gens sont
moins attentifs
non pas par la question et attendait les
sans réponse on en a à 96 donc on n'est
pas loin et paf on attend les laisse
sans réponse
et du coup voilà le graphe de vos
réponses donc assez clairement vous
pencher très largement en faveur du non
et donc la moyenne est à l'hormadi de
prendre la médiane plus tôt que la
moyenne et je pense que je vais prendre
la médiane plus tôt que la moyenne mais
sera-ce tout aussi gore a estimé comme
ça à la louche mais j'ai pas mis en
place tout le truc sympa un peu trop de
temps et c'est un peu galère à faire ce
serait bien qu'ils applications pour
faire ça mais bon en train de demander
du travail bénévole de la part d'autres
joueurs en tout cas la médiane a eu 71
personnes qui soixante douze maintenant
qu'ils ont répondu 0 sur 115 réponse
donc la médiane est clairement à 0 vous
avez répondu 0 à cette question alors je
peux agrandir un petit peu pour mieux
voir et donc ça pour on peut voir niveau
des scores donc ça c'est le chiffre de
fichiers modifiés ne s'est pas de celui
que vous sur lequel vous tombe vous
tombez si vous suivez le lien mais il
faudrait que je vais mettre quelque part
en tout cas ce fichier score il montre
les scores donc doncker ici c'est votre
réponse j'ai répondu 0 eric 0 donc si la
réponse est fausse en fait ça correspond
à cette courbe là si la réponse est
fausse il vous a répondu cinq marqués
zéro point sinon ça des -30 donc et
c'est par contre si la réponse est non
car vous c'est vrai du coup marquer
moins 30 points mais ses réponses et
fosses remarquer +10 points et la
réponse à cette question et fosses donc
félicitations ont commencé par un +10 ça
commence bien
10 alors à la première question est
alors pourquoi est-ce que la réponse est
fausse peut-être fait c'est pas si
évident c'est pas si évident que la
réponse serait clairement clairement
fausse mais il se trouve que l'hypothèse
que l'on fait souvent et qui marche très
très bien en pratique c'est de dire que
chacun des lancers va être indépendant
ça veut dire que chacun lancé va être
aléatoire va être le fruit du hasard
mais
ce hasard ne dépend pas des lancers
précédent et ça si on y réfléchit un
petit peu d'un point de vue
philosophique ça peut paraître assez
étrange surtout si on se dit que le
monde et est totalement déterministe
comme le pensent et la place mais
il se trouve que c'est une hypothèse qui
marche bien en pratique et on a tendance
à l'adopter pour des raisons un peu
payet viennent en fait la réponse que
suggéré par la place c'est que la
réponse serait peut-être même linverse
c'est à dire que si la pièce est tombé
10 fois de plus sur pile alors le pro au
prochain lancée elle a plus de chance de
tomber sur pilc surface pourquoi pas ce
que tu dis non c'est parce qu'elle
pourrait être biaisé et peut-être que en
prenant en compte ce biais de la pièce
et si si vous deviez parier city en
pratique vous deviez parier sur une
pièce qui tombait dix fois sur piles
pour le prochain lancé si vous n'en
savait pas plus et si ya pas de piège
essayez pas de magicien que ça va
probablement parier pile sur le 11e
lancée et est le meilleur pari mais
montrent assez d'émotion un peu un peu
bayésienne de mise à jour de nos
créances aujourd'hui la question qu'on
va s'intéresser à laquelle on va
s'intéresser c'est qu'est ce qui se
passe maintenant s'il n'y a pas de mise
à jour d'un créances que le que la
probabilité qu'une pièce tombe sur un
demi et toujours ce soir tombé sur piles
est toujours égal à 1,2 me
indépendamment de ce qui s'est passé
dans le passé et ce qui est assez
bizarre c'est que vous avez sans doute
entendu parler de la loi des grands
nombres d'une manière ou d'une autre et
en tout cas c'est le sujet de cette
vidéo de ce live est la loi des grands
nombres et nous dit que hockey au
prochain lancée elle tombera pas sur le
fond ce sera indépendant c'est vraiment
l'hypothèse de la loi des grands nombres
c'est que
en tout cas telle qu'elle a été
formalisée ensuite je n'ai pas regardé
toute l'histoire mais j'imagine que
historiquement la loi des grands nombres
a été inventé avant qu'elle a été
formalisée peut-être qui a été inventé
avant que y es-tu ce formalisme et même
la notion d'indépendance et enfin je
sais pas trop les détails pour le coup
mais en tout cas lorsque pascal et fermé
son camp ont commencé à formaliser un
peu la question ce qu'ils on supposait
c'est qu'il y avait vraiment
indépendance et que du coup le prochain
lancé était par hypothèse indépendant
des lancers suivants et le truc très
surprenant savait que même en supposant
cela c'est même en supposant qu'il ait
pas d'effet de compensation il se trouve
que le nombre moyen de piles va tendre
vers la moitié des lancers la moitié des
lancers in fine et sera dès lors ces
piles et on peut avoir l'impression
qu'il ya quelque chose de contradictoire
ici on peut avoir l'impression que je
dis d'un côté qu' il n'y a pas d'effet
de retour à la moyenne et que dans le
côté il y a eu un retour à la moyenne
et bien aujourd'hui le but c'est de
clarifier tout ça et d'aider essayer de
mieux comprendre ce qui se passe
lorsqu'on répète des expériences
indépendante qui ont la même probabilité
on sera peut-être le cas où ils ont pas
forcément les mêmes probabilité mais au
moins lorsque les trucs sont
indépendants il sauf qu'on peut dire
beaucoup de choses sur la moyenne de
ceux qui émergent et c'est vraiment là
le coeur de la loi des grands nombres du
cac le le le l'idée selon laquelle après
dit lundi pile
la pièce a plus de sens mais ce sont
deux chances de sauver surface c'est ce
qu'on appelle le sophisme du parieur et
c'est quelque chose qui ressort est
fréquemment et ça ça veut dire que s'il
ya beaucoup de gens contre qu'il est
possible de gagner de l'argent
ce cas ci on cherchait bien d'argent en
jouant sur ce sophisme
en fait c'est un peu un billet qu'on a
tutti vivement que beaucoup de gens en
tout cas moins intuitive mans et comme
tout bien il peut être exploité
et comme souvent c'est lié à des flux
d'argent c'est quelque chose qui peut
être exploité donc voilà si quelqu'un
très sûr de lui et si s'il a l'air de
mal à réfléchir et qui dit enfin ça fait
10 fois de plus que de suite que c'est
sur piles la prochaine va tourner
surface c'est peut-être le moment de
parier contre lui et de dire de parier
peut-être pas à 50 50 du coût mais
donnez décote à 2 contre 1 par exemple à
1 contre 2 plus tôt donc si c'est le
moment de dire mon bal prochain lancé si
ça tombe en effet surface je te donne 1
mais si ça tombe sur pile tu me donnes 2
si la personne est vraiment sûre d'elle
que ça va tomber sur surface pourrait
accepter et à ce moment là ça serait un
moyen de gamers et poser les choses en
termes de paris c'est aussi une façon de
donner aussi les gens à réfléchir et
peut-être de s'auto des blessés bon
voilà après cette longue introduction
maintenant que tout le monde est arrivé
j'espère jeu facile de devoir encore
frisé sûr sur youtube mais bon je te
fuis thouars 236 on va passer à des
choses un peu plus un peu plus
mathématique est un peu plus un peu plus
en plus étrange voulait dire on va
passer au 2e cuisent alors le deuxième
puise alors bon je sais pas il suffit de
remplacer le cul un parent q2 puisqu'on
passe une deuxième crise et la question
ici est la suivante
si on répète à l'identique et des
mesures aléatoire indépendante x1
jusqu'à xn alors la moyenne mn qui est
égal à saint pie x de 1,6 au sud jusqu'à
xn / n donc c'est la moyenne des xxi
alors cette moyenne convergent lorsque n
tend vers l'infini on prend des mesures
xx1 xl qui sont indépendantes et qui ont
la même distribution donc parfois on
parle de deux variables y idée l'idée ça
veut dire indépendant est identiquement
distribués si l'hypothèse qu'on va
beaucoup faire aujourd'hui et sur une
thèse qui est très souvent fait dans la
littérature et qui est notamment motivée
par un fonds fréquentes east souvent et
cassé une hypothèse très utile parce
qu'elle part parce qu'après ça simplifie
beaucoup de choses on peut faire dire
beaucoup de choses en plus une hypothèse
assez simple à exprimer
alors si on prend ces variables iii-v et
qu'on prend ensuite la moyenne de ces
variables vous appelez mn en moyenne
alors mn temps
enfin convergent taverne limites lorsque
n temps vers l'infini est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est la réponse est plutôt
oui
plus tout non est ce que vous êtes sur
quelle réponse est oui est-ce que vous
être sûr que la réponse est non je vous
laisse réfléchir et je me permets de le
rappeler en avance à sept fois par la
première fois la nervosité est finie
dans le négatif
donc faites attention à l'excès de
confiance et juger le degré de crédence
adéquat à voir au moment de répondre à
ces questions très sûr de vous et qu'en
fait vous pro chez nous mais côté vous
aurez des points très négatif
conformément à la notation qui est
proposé donc si notation qu'on appelle
j'appelle prognathe été une sainte il
compatible on parle aussi de propos
scoring houle pour ceux qui veulent en
savoir plus c'est quelque chose dont
j'ai parlé dans un de mes épisodes dans
ce qui s'appelle les qcm bayésiens parce
que là c'est vraiment récusait
mobilisant donc si on prend des
variables iil est indépendante est
identiquement distribué comprend la
moyenne de beaucoup de ces variables
est-ce que la moyenne va converger vers
l'infini si réfléchir un petit peu
ouais donc c'est variable aléatoire
on mesure ces mots techniques c'est
quantité aléatoire
j'ai mis deux mesures par analogie avec
la physique mais
en mathématiques on parle souvent de
variables aléatoires débat real variable
aléatoire identique et et indépendante
est identiquement distribués est-ce que
la moyenne convergent
lorsqu'un terrain
dont coût donc si vous pensez que la
réponse est oui il faut répondre 10 10
souhaitent sur certains que la réponse
est oui si vous êtes sûr et certain et
que la réponse est non il faut atteindre
0 et si vous êtes un état d'incertitude
maximale vous répondez 5 et puis si vous
pencher d'un côté ou de l'autre
la médiane est plus qu elle fasse il a
quelques et que la moyenne à la louche
comme ça donc c'est peut-être mieux que
enfin là je parle pour estimer
l'agrégation de vos réponses
alors on va dépasser les 100 réponses va
pouvoir passer passer les 100 réponses
de pouvoir passer aux résultats donc
voilà ça c'est à ça que ressemble
l'ensemble de vos réponses donc vous
penchez pencher vers le oui il ya qu'à
absolument non et 31 absolument oui donc
il ya pas mal de gens qui vont avoir des
scores très négatif là donc il ya encore
des réponses qui rentrent donc si je
fais la médiane donc ça se fait 33 plus
ça serait cool et en temps réel si c'est
pas facile donc là j'ai 36 46 65 65
c'est à peu près à moitié chemin jusqu'à
moitié des grecs la médiane est à 8
vous savez que votre réponse médiane de
responsabilité bêta 8 donc air est égal
à 8 donc vous pensez que la moyenne
convergence lorsqu elle tend vers
l'infini et la réponse était faux donc
comment cependant pas bien les gars
c'est une question assez piège donc la
réponse était fausse du coup vous êtes
déjà dans le négatif avec -5 6 points
après des débuts aussi prometteur c'est
c'est dommage alors pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que la médiane prouesse que en
fait c'est une question un peu piège
dans ces tests et c'était juste
le moment où il fallait faire attention
un petit peu et se dira peut-être un
piège et est plutôt qu'à répondre 17
répondre sept ou huit
ça va ça c'est toute la difficulté de
penser de façon probabiliste alors
pourquoi est-ce que la réponse est en
fait non en fait ça vient d'un truc
assez l'étranger découvert par marc
cauchy qui est que en fait certaines
variables non pas de moyenne donc pas
des sans fin le terme technique ses
espérances mais ça c'est un peu ça
l'idée c'est que si je prends beaucoup
de ces variables et ben c'est pas dit
que ça va converger vers un nombre est
l'exemple typique de cette distribution
c'est la loi de kochi vous l'aï déjà dit
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge mais
parce que ça va durer trois heures et
demie à cette fois je me fais pas
d'illusions oh la la
peut-être que ça est plus court aussi
[Musique]
pourquoi il aussi lent alors la loi de
kochi la loi de kochi en fait c'est une
loi alors on peut l'exprimer comme une
oie de discrètes c'est plus naturel à
ddd décrire comme une oie continue
d'ailleurs je ne prenais pas par coeur
le votre coaching
ça dépend d'une d'une constante je vais
tricher un petit peu et voir directement
sur une équipe et gamme donc c'est aussi
rappelé la loi de lawrence est en fait
l'équipe et diomède pas beaucoup reçu
donc c'est une voie qui est définie par
bonds ont défini en fait ce qu'on
appelle à la fonction de densité j'ai
expliqué ce que c'est très bientôt
et cette fonction durant dix cités est
égal à 2 sur tours / 1 + x carré ou tôt
c'est la constante du cercle taux taux
est à peu près égale à 6,28 alors ce qui
importe ici c'est vraiment la dépendance
en x donc c'est une courbe
si je trace la loi de kochi en fait donc
c'est cette fonction là alors je vais
être assez dans des sauces
ce sera plus joli
l'obsession j'aime bien quand c'est
l'inversé en blanc sur noir donc la cour
de cochise donc c'est
donc deux surtout en / + 6 ok ça
ressemble à ça
je vais chez elle c'est si une coupe qui
ressemble à ça qu'ils hockey et qui boit
comme ça comme ça on pourrait dire que
ça ressemble à une loi normale une
courbe en cloche mais elle a une
propriété c'est que la laque eu de
discussion est très épaisse alors on va
reparler des queues de distribution
épaisse dans le prochain épisode sur
scène son rôle ça veut dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de valeurs qui sont très
extrême et ça on peut le voir ou
essayant de calculer la moyenne
rêveur moyenne 2 x ok donc il faut
imaginer que quand on tire quelque chose
selon alain cauchi on tire un point sous
la courbe au hasard et l'abscisse de ce
point sera
la valeur de ce point en question donc
quand je tire un nombre au hasard selon
une loi de kochi c'est comme si je
tirais un point dans la zone rouge ici
donc quand je dis quand je tire une
variable de la loi de kochi c'est comme
si je peux dire est un point au hasard
parmi les points dans la zone en rouge
ici et imaginons que j'ai tiré celui là
et là je regarde son app 6la la
dimension que l'abc cx égal 1
ça vous à dire que j'aurais tiré une
variable qui est
une variable aléatoire qui est égal à 1
et
on peut imaginer prendre l'espérance la
moyenne et si on calcule ça en fait donc
l'espérance de x en fait il ya une façon
de calculer cette cantine voilà
techniquement mon ordi toussote fort dès
le début
l'espérance ce que j'ai des preuves
qu'on critique et ce aujourd'hui donc ça
va être deux surtout peut-être l'écrire
d'abord on est clair comme ça donc
l'expérience donc c'est je fais une
intégrale en fait surtout to her 2 x x
c'est la valeur sous l'espérance fois la
probabilité de tirer x 1 go qui est de
xtx et ça quand le calcul
en gros le remplace fdx par son
expression ça nous fait deux surtout
intégral sur r2 xtx
un de plus six carrés et ça on peut
montrer que ça va pas convergé ça fait
un nombre en gros ça à faire l'infini et
en tunsie mans c'est parce que cette
quantité là cette quantité là à l'infini
ça va être à peu près égal à 1 sur x dx
pour des grandes valeurs de x et or
l'intégrale le 2-1 sur xd x 110 verges
bon pour ceux qui savent assez
équivalent aux log au look naturel qui
qui tend vers l'infini et donc ça c'est
à dire que la loi de kochi n'a pas
d'espérance et c'est assez c'est assez
troublant si vous réfugiez c'est à dire
que si je prends je sais que j'ai une
variable qui suit la loi de cauchy si je
fais plein de tirage de celle ci je fais
plein de tirage de cette loi et que je
prends la moyenne josette et obtenir un
nombre et si je refais ça avec d'autres
données je vais obtenir d'autres nombre
et puis ça va pas convergé ça peut faire
cette fluctuer dans tous les sens c'est
quelque chose qui se comportent en très
très mal donc en général la loi des
grands nombres ne s'applique pas la loi
des concombres nécessite certaines
hypothèses comme par exemple l'existence
d'une espérance
c'est pas c'est pas un truc automatique
ça dépend de d'hypothèses que l'on fait
et est parfois ces hypothèses ne seront
pas vérifié c'est particulièrement en
fait on pourrait se dire ça ce genre de
cas c'est un truc qui n'existe pas en
pratique on pourrait se dire ok là je
suis en train d'inventer un cas purement
mathématique juste pour faire pour faire
chier la loi des grands nombres et c'est
un truc qu'on fait beaucoup en
mathématiques
si pour être honnête mais
malheureusement les trucs à la loi de
kochi sont en fait à 506 arrive jamais
parce qu'il faut de l'infini quelque
part pour procréer des trucs qui font
d'un fini mais en un sens il ya beaucoup
de trucs qui se comporte vraiment comme
si davantage comme si c'était une noix
de coco chic comme si c'était des lois
plus joli plus normale auquel on peut
penser et en particulier c'est le cas
avec des systèmes avec des boucles de
rétroaction
on a souvent des phénomènes comme ça
qu'ils vont faire des queues épaisse il
se trouve que si c'est un truc qui
apparaît un peu au moins sur le temps le
cas de la pandémie provident
en tout cas d'après certaines études je
reparle à la semaine prochaine et en
particulier c'est un truc qui a l'air de
beaucoup à part dans les réseaux sociaux
dans tout ce qui étude des réseaux
sociaux on a souvent c'est que ces
grandes que de descriptions qui font que
juste pensé en termes de l'infini comme
ça de moyenne et de loi des grands
nombres est en fait assez assez trompeur
donc en fait la loi des grands nombres
surtout quand on étudie des systèmes
complexes comme
comme quand l'environnement comme les
réseaux sociaux où il ya des boucles de
rétroaction en fait faut faire super
gaffe c'est c'est loin d'être aussi
aussi donné que ça et la loi des grands
nombres s'applique potentiels n'ont pas
ça c'était un peu la mauvaise nouvelle
on peut passer aux oeufs au troisième
cuisent du coup donc le cuisse 3 donc il
faut en passer par un 3 donc le cuisse 3
dont vous suivez encore une fois le lien
ce 4 à la f3 q3 or c'est assez technique
cette question-là forcer un peu à
raisonner peut-être un peu plus avec des
probabilités
peut-être que ça va sentir un peu
puisque vous pensez vous avez le droit
de dire je ne sais pas de répondre comme
je ne sais pas pressé peu marrant si on
essaie de regarder s'il ya une intuition
qui pourrait indiquer que dans un sens
ou dans l'autre
en tout cas la question est la suivante
c'est que si je prends une variable
aléatoire x positive qui prend toujours
des variables valeur positif donc par
exemple imaginons ceci je lance une
pièce si ça tombe sur piles j'ai vu m x
égal à sa tombe surface le matrix et
gagnent 0 dans une période positive mais
on peut imaginer plein d'autres
variables aléatoires par an
le nombre d'abonnés d'une chaîne il au
hasard sur youtube donc si je prends
cette variable aléatoire alors la
probabilité que cette variable at war
prennent une valeur plus grande que a
est inférieure à l'espérance de x / a
pour toute valeur de à jour ajoutée
positive
ça pose problème
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
question là la réponse à ces questions
là eh oui est ce que c'est cette
inégalité est vrai est-ce que vous
pensez que cette inégalité est fausse
lorsque ça voudra dire intuitivement
c'est à dire que la probabilité des cas
extrêmes est assez faible avec pas elle
peut pas être trop grande
en tout cas c'est forcément qu inférieur
à une constante / la valeur extrême et
cette constante là on peut sont peu à
quelques est numériquement
c'est l'espérance de x ça ça parait je
vais je suis pas qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette équation
si vous dis cela comme ça est ce que à
la louche comme ça est ce que c'est un
truc qui vous paraît raisonnablement
vrai raisonnablement fosse ne sait rien
du tout c'est une réponse tout à fait
possible ce que vous êtes sûr que c'est
vrai ce que tu sûr que c'est faux
peut-être essayer de le démontrer en je
voulais laisser cinq minutes pour
réfléchir
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette école
de cette inégalité est ce que les
valeurs extrêmes d'une variable
aléatoire sont forcément inférieur à 1 /
la valeur extrêmement question x un truc
et qui a à voir avec l'espérance dxo
suivant on peut sentir pourquoi est-ce
que l'espérance apparaître ici
si on place x par par 1000 x x bah alors
donc on peut aussi y égale à 1000 x x un
truc est mille fois plus grand alors la
valeur experts la probité des valeurs
extrêmes soir aussi intimement mille
fois plus grande
on voit pourquoi est-ce que y'a rien
tueur un terme à droite qui seraient
proportionnels à x moi j'veux pas si
vous le sentez mais alors est-ce qu spx
/ ah ça vous semble un bon candidat
[Musique]
et ouais je voulais dire inférieure
également non pas bon ce que j'écris je
voulais dire inférieure à égal
[Musique]
oui pas assez rigoureux
parce que si je prends une et x égal
zéro qui veut toujours zéro malterre de
droite est égal à zéro la probité et
tuer x soit supervision être super eagle
au site ou par les super eagles
cette inégalité parlons donc de
préparation
[Musique]
x est supérieur ou égal à zéro a été
positif ne peut pas être nulle parce
qu'on divise parra à droite et du coup
la question c'est si on a ça est-ce que
la priorité que exprime des valeurs
supérieures et gala est inférieure à
l'espérance de x / a
comment vous le sentez
[Musique]
donc là je mets des supérieurs ou égaux
partout danse à ce que cette inégalité
est alors vrai est-ce que les prêts
étaient des cas extrêmes des croix en
sur la valeur extrêmement question
[Musique]
et
alors pedro demande si il existe une loi
des petits nombres c'est souvent
difficile de dire quoi que ce soit sur
les petits nombres malheureusement je
pense pas tous des bizarreries des
petits noms et je vais dans une vidéo
j'ai cité la loi des petits nombres en
se disant qu'avec des petits nombres on
peut avoir tout et n'importe quoi en
retard sur google en ce moment je vais
tous vous voulez parler aussi c'est la
loi deux hits
je sais pas s'ils ont entendu parler de
la loi de zip c'est un truc très
voyez une excellente vidéo de vie sauce
sur la loi 2 x en anglais qui est un
truc assez assez rigolo qui est rallié
en fête avec eux de distribution et paix
c'est qui qui s'applique au langage
naturel en fait mais aussi dans beaucoup
d'autres car en fait très souvent on
obtient sétois de ziff apparaître dans
des effets de france sans que soit enfin
et des boucles de rétroaction qui fait
que souvent là le énième plus énième
plus grand vous pouvez nième truc qui
apparaît le plus souvent arrivant à
environ une fois moins souvent que le
plus dur est le plus fréquent que le
énième mots du vocabulaire français le
plus utilisé apparaît empiriquement à
peu près une fois moins souvent que le
mot le plus utilisé dans la langue
française ça marche avec pas mal de
trucs
pas sûr les youtuber peut-être que ça
commence à saturer sur youtube mais
pendant une époque ça marchait pas mal
avec les youtube heures le énième plus
gros youtuber à une fois moins d'abonnés
que le plus gros du tout
ok aux sommes plus que trois réponses et
on va pouvoir passer trois personnes
pour répondre
[Musique]
à l'étroit réponse que deux
et plus qu'une réponse on y est combien
de temps faut attendre attendre pour
avoir une réponse sachant qu'ils avaient
dû 99 je vais réfléchir à ça donc assez
bon ok donc ça ressemble à sa
disposition de vos résultats donc
beaucoup d'incertitudes ça s'étale de 0
à 10 de façon très et alim saran le
calcul la médiane plus compliqué donc à
peu près 30 45 quand tu vois lancia la
médiane est à 5
vous répondez en médiane je ne sais pas
[Musique]
qui tu es ça donc si vous répondez
je ne sais pas ben je ne sais pas ça
veut dire que quel soit bleue où la
courbe bleue où la courbe verte ont
marqué zéro point et du coup plus 0 au
moins vous n'avez pas perdu de poids une
bonne chose surtout sachant que j'ai mal
posé la question il me initialement
la réponse à cette question est oui
donc le ccsa c'est le toit un théorème
qui s'appelle l'inégalité de markov
du mathématicien markov connais pas
grand chose d'ailleurs sur ce
mathématicien
tabet est plus fatigué encore que
d'habitude
grâce
donc il ya des inégalités de markov donc
c'est exactement ce qu'on vient de dire
donc la probabilité qu'une variable
prennent une valeur extrême une variable
positive prennent une valeur extrêmes on
va y arriver aujourd'hui est inférieur
ou égal à l'espérance de x / alors la
démonstration de ça on va faire la
démonstration est lié la démonstration
c'est qu'on va regarder d'abord
l'espérance donc c'est prendre avoir
moyenne des valeurs de x donc là je vais
être assez fort sur gironde est quand
même plus vite ce sera plus joli
donc pour comprendre pourquoi ça marche
on va regarder la fonction f 2 x est
égal à x donc ça c'est la fonction
publique c'est égal à x et quand on
prend l'espérance de x on va prendre une
valeur moyenne l'avoir moyenne des
points lorsque je tire x moyenne en tout
cas de l'ordonner de ces points qui
aiment que l'ap 6 et on va comparer ça à
une autre fonction
si je veux réussir à l'écrire comment
l'écrire en fait qui est égal à 1 6x est
supérieur ou égal à à diviser par a + 0
sinon parce que c'est ça marche non
je fais un bon c'est la fonction qui qui
qui qui qui lorsqu'on arrive à aa
lorsqu'il que c'est plus grand qu à elle
va valoir un sur a donc là c'est le cas
où a été égal à un bond à peu près
n'importe quelle valeur positive on a
dit et donc la part égale à 1 c'est faux
a gardé cette fonction donc donc là sa
fonction qui vaut à lorsque x est super
avec gala c'est plus de sens donc dès
que avec eux est ce qu'on voit c'est que
et qui est égal à zéro avant que je le
tenais notre fonction c'est zéro parce
que x est inférieur à ça ces deux
morceaux de corps bleu vert et et le
orange sur la même courbe vous donner la
même couleur et donc là ce qu'on voit
c'est que la courbe bleue avec ses
dégâts les x est toujours au dessus de
la courbe orange
c'est vraiment ça qu'on va utiliser dans
l'inégalité de markov et ça nous dit que
x est toujours supérieure ou égale
donc la courbe orange souvent on
l'appelle donc a donc c'est à x 1
e
si x est égal à aspirer gala tablette
rame à mort je pense qu'ils je pense
qu'on va faire une pause d'essayer de
régler ça désolé je pense pouvoir
revenir sur le même saut mines peut-être
falloir changer de streaming ce que je
peux reprendre un streaming
ok c'est l'impression d'être revenu sert
de marché je pense que ça
voilà j'ai réduit la qualité de l'image
j'espère que ça va réduire aussi à
améliorer la capacité de
je pense qu'il est urgent et important
d'avoir une machine c'est complètement
nul
mais par contre
ça rame à mort je précise
[Musique]
bon ce qui est plus réactif
alors que je pensais avoir d'autres
matériels je sais pas comment faire
un peu plus écrire passer une
démonstration via le texte donc on sait
que x et
x est supérieur ou égal à a fois 1 6x et
supérieur et gala a donc ça c'est
l'inégalité fondamentale
et ensuite on va prendre l'espérance des
deux côtés
l'espérance de a à x 1,6 x est supérieur
à 1
[Musique]
est ce que le streaming fonctionne
encore
[Musique]
et du coup on a l'espérance de x qui est
super et régale donc l'espérance d'une
constante fois une variable aléatoire ca
fois l'espérance de la variable at war 2
1 6 et supérieures et gala a en fait
l'espérance de 1,6 x est super gala
c'est comme s'ils ont marqué un point à
chaque fois que x est supérieur à égal à
zéro lorsque x est inférieure à et ça ça
revient raconte exactement une fois en
gros à chaque fois que je lis espérer
gara et regarder la moyenne des cas du
cou ou x est supérieure à la moyenne des
cas où x est super eagle a en fait c'est
égal à la probabilité que x fois
supérieure et gallard et du coup on
divise en parlera des deux côtés on a le
duc ou l'inégalité de markov qui dit que
la probabilité que x est supérieur ou
égal à est inférieur
à l'espérance de x / a
j'espère que c'était à peu près clair et
tout ça fonctionne c'est faux faux faux
faux que la première inégalité soit soit
va il faut que l'aixois super positif
soit x au superbe gala à 0 mais une fois
qu'on a ça tout le reste fonctionne très
bien on à l'inégalité de markov ce que
ce qui est du programme autorisé à
écrire à nouveau
suspense non il veut toujours pas écrire
ça ruine un peu mon live tout ça bon
voici tout faire par écrit par texte
parce que donc l'une conséquence denis
gâté de markov qui est vraiment unique a
été fondamental pour étudier les valeurs
extrêmes
ça va être l'inégalité de biens aimés et
y habite chef thierry gaiffe et
plusieurs écrits cuir aux orthographes
pour cheat chef j'aime avec les bonnes
séries comme sa réponse et sa bien aimée
tié bi jeff et l'inégalité de desbiens
et métiers huit chefs liés c'est que moi
poser idrac est égal à x - l'espérance
de x au carré qui est une variable
aléatoire donc défini à partir de x et
qui
et qui est positif de façon importante
donc si tu vas abattoirs positif donc on
peut l'appliquer
l'inégalité de markov ali à la variable
y est ça nous dit que la probabilité que
y soient supérieurs égal à aa est
inférieure à l'espérance de y
au carré / ap et ça c'est très
intéressant parce que l'espérance de les
grecs car et là on reconnaît mme on peut
remplacer par son expression ici et
l'espérance de x - x l'espérance de l'x
au carré ça c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi
la variance de xc à quel point est-ce
que x varie autour de sa moyenne
donc ça c'est moins cool et le fait
qu'ils y soient supérieurs gala à ça
veut aussi dire que x se dire ça et
maintenant si je remplace à part par des
carrés ont déclaré
bah ça nous donne cette inégalité là et
à gauche on peut prendre six ici un truc
on peut prendre racine carrée des deux
côtés donc si je prends la racine carrée
des deux côtés samedi à valeur absolue
de x - l'espérance de x et le côté on
aurait juste b mais on obtient cette
inégalité la crise à ces inégalités de
tché bi tché qui est déduite directement
de l'inégalité de markov du coup en
posant tout simplement y est égal à x -
les spurs de x au carré que j'écris une
bêtise ouais
de quoi
[Musique]
et est en fait c'est cette inégalité est
vraiment très intéressante parce que ça
nous dit à quel point xv a dévié donc
souvent ce qu'on aura regardé ces s'est
lui dit qu avec les poings xv a dévié de
sa moyenne pour n'importe quel variable
x ça ça s'applique à tous de variables x
alors pourvu qu'elles aient une
espérance ça va pas s'appliquer du cou à
la loi de kochi qu'on a vus mais pour la
plupart des variables x donc x -
l'espérance de x va nous dire on est
capable de dire à quel point c'est rare
que x s'éloigne de son espérance
il savait en partie quand on va
contrôler sa part une autre quantité qui
s'appelle la variance la variance était
x
[Musique]
avait on peut faire du l'attaqué avec
son temps découvert un truc qui m'a mis
sans commentaire
au hockey des coûts et un triple vous
allez expression avec du latex c'est
plus joli
ok on va pouvoir passer du coup à un
merci je sais pas qui victor pour ses
tricks et c'est un pool très salloukh
ok on va passer 4e cuisent de me classer
et le quatrième cuisent on voit ici que
l'importance de la variance pour étudier
les variations extrêmes et en
particulier les variations par rapport à
la moyenne mais ça dans l'optique de
de la loi des grands nombres ça va être
extrêmement utile puisque à wade grand
nombre nous dit qu'on tombe sur la
moyenne après beaucoup d'itérations ont
envie de dire au moins lorsque
l'espérance est bien défini bah les cas
extrêmes son sang sont rares donc le
quatrième cuisse nous dit sa jolie me
dis que si on prendre des variables
aléatoires x et y
alors la variance 2x plus y est égale à
la variance 2x plus avare y ont fait un
retour avec
voilà est-ce que penser que c'est vrai
[Musique]
est ce que pensent et à quel point vous
êtes sûr de vous si je prends deux
variables x et y
on peut faire la somme de ces de varades
x plus y nous dit à quel point
enfin c'est la somme des deux variables
donc on mesure par exemple la
température et sur terre et on mesure
autre chose c'est pas des nombres de
lapin voilà prendre deux variables x et
y
est ce que à quel point c'est lorsque je
fais la somme savary à ce que la
variance de la sones est-ce que ça c'est
égal à la variance du premier plus la
variance du deuxième qu'est ce que vous
pensez parce que la réponse est plutôt
oui plutôt non plus tôt je ne sais pas
qu'en penser
[Musique]
double dollars pour un véhicule
alors j'aurai appris quelque chose
d'important aujourd'hui à aa merci
victor ainsi pratiquer en fait les
riders hockey de la question à ce que la
variance d'une somme est égale à la
somme des variances ce que ça commute
ces deux opérateurs
c'est parce que je compte de variables
aléatoires et que je regarde leur somme
ça va varier autant que la somme des
variances de chacune des variables est
ce que pense la réponse est oui non
peut-être à quel point est-ce que vous
êtes sûr de vous
[Musique]
ce
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
ok donc lui nombre de réponses ou
beaucoup trop mon pouvoir passer à la
réponse du coup pas s'entraîner
et
donc la plupart des réponses faites la
médiane ici était cette fois était à
zéro ce qui à 57 réponse et 36 02 vous
êtes sûr de vous que la réponse est non
et en effet la réponse fait en effet la
réponse est non du coup vous marquer 10
points
hier john key alors pourquoi est-ce que
la réponse est non bah en fait il ya est
ce que quelqu'un peut une démonstration
de jolis en tête
en fait il une façon très simple de voir
qu'à réponse est non c'est le supposer
que que y est égal à - x16 y est égal à
moins 6
[Musique]
x6 y est égal à moins x alors x plus y
est égal à x 9 x est égal à zéro
or clairement une variable qui vaut tout
se dire qu'une variable qui vaut
toujours zéro x ou y
or clairement une variable qui vaut
toujours zéro elle a aucune variance
tous cas elle varie pas donc la variance
dx plus y ait forcément égal à zéro or
si on prend une variable x qui a une
variance chi chi l'observance est pile
ou face
parfois savary on peut choisir x tel que
var 2 x 14 x est égal est vraiment dur
est strictement positif et à ce moment
là bas le le le le terme de gauche va il
expulse y bat ça c'est légal à zéro donc
à gauche on a zéro
mais à droite voyons s'il faudrait que
disent la variance de -6 en fait c'est
la même cadence de x ça sent
effectivement si je remplace x par - x
c'est comme si je flippais x mais il ya
toujours autant varié il soit par les
durs autant que -6 et du coup à droite
ce sera strictement positif alors qu'à
gauche ce sera égal à zéro et donc là en
un contre exemple qui montre que
voilà la variance la somme n'est pas la
somme des variances est en fait le par
contre le théorème on a quand même un
théorème important alors je crois que
c'est esthétique est double pour un
nouveau super qui il veut mieux
fonctionner on a quand même un théorème
pas encore ultra fluide mais c'est
beaucoup mieux qu'avant
donc moi un théorème qui dit que si x et
y sont indépendants donc donc xy
indépendance ça veut dire quoi
formellement vendredi apparaît
d'ailleurs dans son et parler de la
théorie de l'information mais en gros
quand x et y sont indépendants ça veut
dire que
profitez de x sachant y est égal à
profiter de xl on le fait de connaître
quelques noms changent rien et ça plus
fondamentalement ça s'écrit voit la
probabilité selon xy d'avoir x et y
c'est toujours égale à pro a été d'avoir
x fois la probabilité d'avoir y pour
toutes xe pour toute valeur possible des
xy la probabilité d'avoir x et y
ces gars-là a profité d'avoir 2 x fois
la pro a été d'avoir y est donc là une
modification ça va être important pour
la suite cette multiplication
mais mon problème pour le pense on s'en
fout un peu
donc si on a ça alors les variances
s'additionnent la variance 2x plus y il
fatigue à nouveau
et ils vont pas fiable donc la barre the
xx plus y c'est la variance 2x plus la
variance des grecs avec l'indépendance
je veux pas le démontrer parce que parce
que ça me fatigue d'écrire sur c'est ce
que je vous dis un peu fatigué qui est
un peu long mais en fait vous pouvez le
démontrer en utilisant la définition je
donnais sketch de preuve les théorèmes
c'est que x ou y
oryx
donc le théorème c'est ça ces orphelins
livrés indépendant des grecs alors les
variances s'additionnent et pour
démontrer sa la preuve de sa
[Musique]
démonstration c'est juste de réutiliser
à définition donc fait var 2 x alors
peut-être une façon de simplifier la
preuve c'est que si on déplace en transe
latics si on fait x plus une constante
alors la variance ne change pas un
activement la variance à quel point ça
varie donc c'est juste une des places x
la barre je ne bouge pas donc on peut
supposer sans faire de généralité
l'espérance de x et l espérance d y est
égal à zéro
ça va simplifier les calculs cyniques ou
est-ce qu'on va beaucoup faire par la
suite c'est juste pour simplifier les
calculs on peut se ramener au cas où
l'expérience est pas nul ensuite
avec ces histoires de translation
messieurs si on a ça on voit que donc la
variance 2x plus y
c'est en fait égal à l'espérance de luxe
plus y au carré et ça vous pouvez le
développer et on re ça va être bon
écrire la preuve finalement disais que
je n'écrirai pas à mémoire de xy
voilà je développe et en fait donc
l'espérance d'une somme c'est la somme
des espérances en l'espérance a été un
opérateur linéaire la moyenne de deux
variables aléatoires c'est la somme des
moyennes donc ça se voit bien aussi si
vous écris la définition de l'espérance
du coup ça c'est aussi ça découpe est
partout
et l'espérance de x au carré plus
espérances des grecs qui caresse à ses
variantes en fait on retrouve ici
vardy x + loire de y est on a un autre
terme qui est l'esprit et de foi
l'espérance de xy
il se trouve que l'espérance de xy comme
x et y sont indépendants c'est égal à
l'espérance de x fois l'espérance de y
pour comprendre pourquoi c'est le cas
pour pouvoir venir définition de caisse
que qu'est ce que devra blindés
indépendante
là par contre je vais vous laisser
vérifier ça chez vous si vous voulez
france un bon exercice suffit de décrire
l'expression est là ce qu'on voit c'est
que l'on exposé que l'espérance de x est
égale espérances de y est égal à zéro
donc ce terme est égal à zéro
si ça marche
[Musique]
j'étais trop ambitieux avec elle ben si
ça va parce que
et du coup on retrouve exactement var
dxp sauvegarder y découvre potentiel de
faire bien writer
donc là on a la démonstration que si x
et y sont orthogonaux la variance la
somme est la somme des vies des marlins
et ça ça va nous permettre de démontrer
la loi des grands nombres de cas une
version faible de la loi des grands
nombres
[Musique]
pourquoi bat simplement
donc si on a x1 et x2 xn des variables
indépendantes est identiquement
distribués et on va supposer avec
espérance et variance fini alors c'est à
dire quoi ça veut dire que en fait il ya
des lois de des lois de probabilité
comme la loi de kochi qui n'ont pas
espérant pas d'espérance et qui n'ont
pas de variance non plus tu auras avec
cette même idée qu'il ya des cas trop
extrêmes qui font que ceux ci ont
regardé à quel point ça varie et
comprenait amont en fait avancer une
moyenne dès les quarts et la déviation à
la moyenne est en fait il ya certaines
lois qui varient trop et du coup là bas
rhin c'est infini donc si on ne prend
pas ces lois qui sont un peu
problématique si on suppose que
variables sont
[Musique]
espérance et variance fini alors mn mn
ça va être la moyenne à ce moment là on
va démontrer c'est que la probabilité
que l'on va se poser aussi que espérance
nul dire que les variables sont centrés
encore une fois on pourra l'aider centre
et en rajoutant une constante mais pour
simplifier les calculs on va se poser
que l'espérance est nuls et ce qui nous
a intéressés c'est de voir à quel point
est-ce que la moyenne des vies après été
que ça soit plus grand que être ypsilon
donc voilà donc si on prend x1 xn des
variables indépendantes est identique
ont distribué avec une espérance nul et
une balance une hymne
alors la probité de
qui on est des valeurs extrêmes là on va
pouvoir appliquer le théorème de bien
aimer les inégalités de bien aimer
timide chef
donc ça ça va être du coût inférieur à
la variance 2mn / epsilon carré
ça s'est il a été de biens numériques f
est ce qu'il va être intéressant c'est
que maintenant on peut calculer à
valence 2 mn en fonction de ce conseil
des variables x1 jusqu'à xl puisque mn
[Musique]
m nc lason c'est 1 sur rennes
la moyenne écrire c'est comme ça x est
un plus
[Musique]
m
m nc la moyenne des x l x y et du coup
la variance de mnc du coup par ce sont
automatiques la base elle-même c'est la
variance de se taire et donc là il ya
deux astuces qu'on va trouver
on va utiliser les propriétés de la
balance la première c'est que la
variance d'une constante fois un nombre
en fait ça il suffit d'écrire son
expression en tant qu espérances et ça
va faire faire ce nombre hockey au carré
donc on fait on peut sortir la constante
1 sur rennes ce couple ça on peut
peut-être leur écrire un break sur de
vin de suresnes
oui
il
ce que le problème
et le pit
il finit avec un égal il veut pas que
finisse avec un régal et donc on a cette
inégalité on peut sortir le 1 sur rennes
et ça va faire un truc me lemieux au
carré donc ça va être égal à 1 / m² fois
la variance de l'asean et là on va
utiliser ce qu'on vient de voir le fait
que je la variance d'une somme et c'est
la somme des variants sorte que ces
variables sont indépendantes c'est là
qu'ont utilisé l'hypothèse
d'indépendance et du coup ça va me faire
sur l occar et de vars de x ore
et
[Musique]
la barre 2 mn c'est donc la variance de
1 sur rennes fois la sones c'est égal à
1 sur une car il faut la variance de
l'asean qui est égal à 1 sur une carré
fois la scène des variances ans la somme
des balances et sont les mêmes on va
utiliser le fait que son récent raison
la même distribution
du coup ça va être une fois la variance
de l'un d'entre eux donc c'est une fois
la variance vous appelez ça x pour la
une de ces variables et là on a dû 1 /
m² fois n 2 fois bar the xx est égal à
valence 2 x / n donc c'est simplement
une cellule et on obtient sa cavale en
ce domaine est égal à 1 sur rennes fois
la variance 2x et donc ça je peux
rapport remettre ça dans l'équation ci
dessus qui est donc égale à 1 sur aisne
epsilon quart et barreur x
et là ce qu'on va faire c'est vrai faire
tendre n vers l'infini et quand on tend
vers l'infini belle expression c'est du
un sur et donc ça tend vers zéro vient
de démontrer un théorème faible du de la
loi des grands nombres qui nous dit que
[Musique]
la moyenne ne peut pas s'écarter trop de
l'espérance donc là on a pris
l'espérance est égal à zéro mais en fait
ça se généralise à n'importe quelle
espérance
essentiellement c'est la même preuve
enlever cette hypothèse
pourvu que la variance de la discussion
c'est fini alors on a montré assez
facilement en utilisant ses propres été
lavé relance que la loi des grands
nombres le fait que c'est improbable que
la moyenne des vies de plus deux pilotes
et en particulier cette profiter de
temps vers zéro
[Musique]
- gros voilà donc là on va pouvoir
passer du coup au quiz suivant le
cinquième cuisent
[Musique]
le cinquième cuisent
c'est si on suppose que pour tout epson
positif la limite quand même temps vers
l'infini de la probabilité que la moule
l'écart par rapport à la moyenne soit
plus petit que les pilotes si je sais
que cette probabilité à temps vers zéro
alors je peux dire que d'un moyenne tend
vers zéro
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
à une question sur la deuxième question
donc c'est la loi de kochi kiki qui
posait problème et plus plus gréement en
fait le problème à voir et que son appel
les lois de puissance loi de puissance
c'est ce qui pose problème parce
qu'elles ont plus d'espérance fini ou de
valence le fini ça y ait plusieurs ces
types de loi de puissance donc ça peut
varier d'une voix de puissance et
l'autre gars et maintenant on se pose la
question alors ça peut paraître bizarre
peut-être que je vais essayer de
débroussailler un peu ce que ce que je
en train de dire par là là c'est ce
qu'on a démontré c'est que si je prends
n'importe quel déviation ben j'ai envie
de dire que pendant que je reprends mes
lancers pile ou face
et ils ont envie de dire que en moyenne
je vais faire la moitié de mes lancers
la moyenne en moyenne moitié de mes
lancers des piles
mais si je regarde en pratique si le
fait une série de lancers en pratique la
moyenne ne sera pas exactement un demi
elle va dévier de 1/2 avec une erreur
qui veulent pas ici epsilon qu'est ce
que je dis c'est que quelques bouts
soual l'erreur que je prends
ce qu'on vient de démontrer c'est que il
pourra lancer pièce
l'espérance est fini mais bon c'est fini
donc tout va bien je viens de démontrer
c'est que quelle que soit l'erreur si
j'ai envie de dire que je serai à à la
moitié de deux piles avec une erreur
relative avec une erreur absolue taux de
1 milliardième va dire donc cesser le
jeu sans rien dire que la preuve était
que l'erreur que je fais par rapport à
un pile en pratique sur sur un milliard
de fin sur un certain nombre de lancers
n les avoirs que je fais par rapport à
un demi si je suppose que c'est
inférieur à 6 je regarde le cas où
l'erreur et est un milliardaire
eh bien lorsque fait de plus en plus de
lancer la probabilité que je tourne dans
cet intervalle d'erreur tend vers un ou
dit autrement la probabilité que je dis
et des valeurs plus extrêmes qui
s'éloigne de un demi de plus que et
pilonnent depuis ce qu'un milliard de
yens la probabilité de s'écarter puisque
ça tend vers zéro et donc elle est aussi
faible que l'on veut dans le mois cette
propriété là sera un sur 10 pions sur
google si on veut mais il faut prendre
dans un nombre de lancers suffisamment
est la question que je pose assez est-ce
que sa chance à ça suffit à démontrer
que forcément
la moyenne va tendre vers zéro j'allais
dire que si je prends ensuite de lancer
alors forcément je rende moyenne
empirique cette moyenne empirique va
forcément tendre vers un demi exactement
ce que les deux sont équivalents ou
plutôt est ce que première pique les
yeux alors pourquoi est-ce que ça peut
être important en pratique en pratique
on peut imaginer que mon disque quelque
chose et est très probable et plus on a
de donner plus ce sera probable que du
coup la déviation sera inférieur à
epsilon c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose de dire que quoi qu'il arrive on
sait qu'on finira par avoir nombre de
lancers qui est égal à 1 2 me à l'infini
il ya une petite subtilité jeu parce que
vous arrivez à la sentir la question
c'est est-ce que les deux notions
c'est juste une subtilité mais en fait
elles sont équivalentes ou toulouse
jusqu'à le premier avec la deuxième ou
est ce qu'il ya une voie subtilité qui
fait qu' il ya des cas où on peut avoir
l'air le 1er mai où le deuxième ne
n'arrivera pas
c'est yahia supérieur est ce que le fait
que les valeurs celles s'écarte de plus
que les pilotes elle soit improbable
donc la probabilité de déviation de plus
captiale est égal à zéro
ça implique que la moyenne empirique
temps effectivement vers zéro donc c'est
un peu joué avec votre intuition
mathématiques
donc il
[Musique]
compliqué d'y répondre
or
bon voilà la réponse
donc c'est une question assez technique
subtilité qui est difficile à comprendre
mais je vous invite à essayer d'y
réfléchir
en fait l'arbre la médiane et qu'il faut
arriver jusqu'à 19 11 12 ans 12-13 17 18
mois hier comme médiane et à 3 donc la
médiane et à 3 la bonne réponse était en
fait nous pencher du bon côté la bonne
réponse était en fait non les deux sont
pas équivalents vous marquez 6,4 points
yep et la raison pour laquelle c'est pas
équivalents
c'est la subtilité entre son appel la
loi faible des grands nombres et la loi
forte des grands nombres donc donc la
bvg or j'avais prévu de faire la
démonstration des lois fortes mais je
pense que non fait sauter sa difficulté
en gros la loi faible des grands nombres
ça veut dire que oui il est improbable
que la moyenne des villes moyennes
empirique des vies de l'espérance
surtout quand on est grand
alors que la loi forte dit un truc un
petit peu différent elle dit que on est
sûr sûr c'est à dire probabilité ainsi
une petite petite technicalité
mathématiques mais c'est à dire qu'on
est sûr fois parfois c'est appeler
presque sûrement devenir presque sûr
mais c'est la pro a était un
on est sûr que la moyenne a pour limites
l'espérance vous voyez il ya une petite
technicalité
[Musique]
vient du fait que la loi la loi forte et
un peu plus forte
c'est quelque chose qui est plus
difficile à démontrer et qui est moins
valides il ya besoin de peut-être plus y
est je suis exactement de cela ce que
moi j'avais prévu de démontrer papote
pour vos vacances finies c'est possible
qu'il ait technicalité en fait c'est de
mémoire en tout cas la loi faible ne
nécessite pas que la variance soit fini
et à la loi forte non plus dans la foule
la loi forte non plus donc j'ai spécifié
une différence si une différence est
vraiment très technique
non en gros ces lois s'appliquent quand
il ya une espérance vérifier ça c'est
pas un cours très solide que je suis
conscient et est donc là technicalité
vient du fait que est ce qu'on est sûr
que ça finira pas on est sûr que
l'événement va arriver et l'événement
étant la convergence alors que la loi
faible elle dit pour une grande valeur
de haine cette probabilité est très très
faible
c'est un peu une cervelle à la loi
faible elle nous dit plus quelque chose
sur sur un échantillon de données en
pratique il dit que la probabilité est
très faible
en tout cas pour une balance fini après
il est inversée pas fini je suis pas sûr
qu'on arrive à bien contrôler ce qui se
passe mais c'est un peu il ya une petite
subtilité entre les deux qui fait que ça
c'est c'est fou tout cas lorsque la
barre c'est fini c'est très facile à
démontrer on l'a fait ça même lorsqu'à
warrants c'est fini c'est compliqué à
démontrer se pose un peu plus technique
c'est pas mal plus technique mais ça se
démontre un jour a pu le démontrer
c'est juste que c'est plus facile 6 à
6,6 ici un support autre que que du
texte
ok on va passer du coup au 6e cuisent
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on va finir en 3 heures mais
souhaite plein de choses
[Musique]
ok donc sachant tout ce qu'on a vu avec
la loi voir tes tout ça est ce que ça ça
vous semble vrai on prend une pièce
équilibré donc ouais suppose que chaque
lancer indépendant et tout ça et on
appelle pn le nombre est bien faible et
nombre de piles et de phase après rennes
lens est indépendant et dts et tout ça
alors la probabilité avec prométhéen est
ce qu'on peut dire que le nombre de
piles - le nombre de faces tend vers
zéro c'est à dire que il y aura autant
de piles que de face parce qu'on sait
que ça c'est plutôt vrai ou plutôt flou
je comprend une pièce équilibré on
appelle pn le nombre de piles et a fait
nombre de faces règne dans ces
indépendants est ce que on peut dire que
le nombre de piles sera moins le nombre
de faces et tend vers zéro c'est nous
deux piles et non de face je fais la
différence est l'erreur entre deux
pylônes de fass est ce que ça 7 environ
0 c'est sans doute la question la plus
importante d'aujourd'hui je pense pour
en tout cas clarifier le sophisme du
parieur est la loi des grands nombres
je pense que s'il ya un truc à retenir
de la loi des grands nombres c'est
quelque chose par rapport à ça parce que
bon ça qu'on a vu des trucs un peu trop
technique aux frais que on souhaite un
peu mieux mes cours pour ses lives pour
pour quel technicalité sox plus
croissante est ce que là c'était assez
technique
[Musique]
on revient un truc à peu près que plus
compréhensible en tout cas la question
c'est est-ce que le nombre de piles et
nous de façon être juste ego congo en
soutenant quasiment égaux de sorte que
l'écart entre les deux camps adverses 0
[Musique]
oui quand même temps vers l'infini
c
on prend une pièce équilibré est ce que
le nombre de piles et de face comme
élancé indépendant
l'écart entre les deux pylônes de face
dans vers zéro
[Musique]
la musique stress
moi je l'entends pas la musique du coup
[Musique]
oui
comment se comporte le nombre de piles
et non de face j'aurais dû quand c'est
plus rapidement par cette question de
ses rangs une question concernant le
coeur trucs plus important est de
comprendre
[Musique]
et ça se voit pas mal dans les votes
d'ailleurs qui aurait pas ses résultats
enfin dans les votes dans les réponses
donc ça donne ça et comme vous voyez il
ya eu ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
trucs en vue ça veut dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à quoi beaucoup
d'excès de confiance ou moins d'un côté
et du coup il ya des choses importantes
à corriger vous serez téhéran beaucoup
mieux que je commence pas mal par cette
question
donc alors la médiane dans tout ça pour
arriver à 18 plus six a fait 24 ans que
la moyenne la médiane et a en elle est
très différente de la moyenne puisque
moyenne sera beaucoup plus proche se
tire beaucoup d'autres côtés mais à
médiane et à 1 et je pense que ces cas
où la médiane est beaucoup plus solide
que la moyenne ce que répond c'est en
effet et n'ont donc vous c'est faux du
coup marc et 9,6 points si vous fait
maintenant vingt ans solidement dans le
positif et même si épéistes - 15,6 ça
serait vraiment bien alors pourquoi
est-ce que la réponse est non le c'est
vraiment le truc important à comprendre
c'est que c'est la moyenne du nombre de
cas qui convergent mai
et comprend la moyenne on divise par par
le nombre de lancers c'est pas juste le
nombre de piles
c'est le nombre de piles / n pas énoncer
c'est ça qui va converger vers 1 heure
1/2 avec probabilité
d'après la loi des grands noms mais tout
ça
mais le nombre lui-même de lancer il va
pas convergé fin il va pouvoir il va pas
convergé va tendre vers l'infini
en plus de ça si on regarde l'écart
entre pn et fbn savez c'est un truc à
faire beaucoup de fluctuations et en
fait ça va faire des fluctuations qui
n'ont jamais su rapprocher de zéro qui
ont même s'éloigner de zéro il faut
imaginer c'est un truc qui va aussi et
de plus en plus comme ça mais dont
l'amplitude d'oscillations il va être
plus en fait de l'ordre de racine carrée
de m c'était c'est vraiment le truc à à
comprendre c'est que en fait dpn - fn
si je prenais alors absolue lors la
bonne approximation de ça c'est plus un
truc de l'ordre de racine carrée de l
donc ça c'est pas très riches fassent
pas rigolo ce que j'écris c'est pas dire
grand chose mais c'est un peu
l'intuition qu'il faut avoir derrière
l'adversaire c'est les choses qui
varient et ya pas de certaine manière le
truc un peu magique avec la loi des
grands nombres
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de force de rappel
n'y a pas de raison pour que les deux se
rapprochent à part le truc enfin le la
raison pour laquelle ça sera vrai c'est
qu'on divise par n est que lorsqu on
divise par nc cesser ces perturbations
sont elles grandissent pas assez vite
l'écart entre les deux grandi comme
racine carrée de haine mais après on
divise par haine du coup ça devient
beaucoup plus petit et ça c'est fait un
truc qui tend vers zéro mais l'écart
absolu l'écart absolu entre les piles et
les faces lui va augmenter en fait il va
pas augmenter dans la plus parce qu'il
n'y a pas de force de rappel donc si un
instant t c'est un instant c'est au bout
de mille danse et on a obtenu 1000 pile
de plus que deux fasse don non c'est pas
possible c'est après un million de
lancer on a 1000 pis mille pile de plus
que de face et si on devait parier sur
ce qui aurait plus de piles ou de face
dans deux millions de lancer et en
particulier la différence entre les
piles et les faces et bien le le pari le
plus probable sur vos paris sur un seul
nom parce qu'il a travaillé mais si on
doit parler sur un an ce nombre s'est ne
paraît que cette différence va rester
teltec telle qu'elle va rester de
l'ordre de 2 me avec elle va rester muet
à l'âme il
mais ce qui est plus plus probables sont
des crises a comme son probabiliste
médias savent pas tendre vers zéro n'y a
pas de force de rappel
ça va rester milles sur garde
l'espérance ça va être mille de paix de
haine - f2 n
sachant que après millions de danse et
ses différences et égale à 1000
l'espérance après 2 millions de lancer
ce sera à 1000 parce que l'écart est
déjà 2000
mais maintenant si on regarde on regarde
de façon un peu plus probabiliste et on
regarde quelles sont les valeurs les
plus probables de dans la différence
entre p2m - f2 n en valeur absolue la
sas à avoir tant ça augmente et serait
de l'ordre de racine carrée de haine
donc ça c'est vraiment le truc à
comprendre ce qu'il n'y a pas de force
de rappel il y aura des fluctuations et
les fluctuations vont augmenter en
valeur absolue mais si on regarde
l'erreur à lahti vrai relative sur ce
qu'on divise tout par par par n 1 go à
ce moment là tout va disparaître et et à
quel point ça va les fluctuations vont
grandir ça va être de l'ordre de racine
carrée de haine ont valeur absolue du
coup la valeur absolue va va augmenter
avec une taille racine carrée de haine
mais leur relative décroître du coup en
insu racines canadiennes qui a vraiment
ce racine carrée de haine qui équipe qui
vend pas facile à saisir mais c'est
vraiment de l'intuition clés à avoir
c'est que ça à faire des fluctuations de
l'ordre de racine carrée de haine et ses
fluctuations statistiques en valeur
absolue ne vont pas disparaître
au contraire elles vont augmenter
mais ça ça nous amènera au théorème le
plus le plus le drame le plus formidable
je vais dire moyen terme de beille c'est
vrai cliqué plus formidable que tom
centrale limite mais dans ces histoires
de fluctuation de loi des grands nombres
férule le théorème plus important que la
loi des grands nombres surtout en
pratique c'est le théorème centrale
limite qui est la version formaliser de
ce que je viens de dire
le théorème centrale limite ce qu'il dit
c'est que cette fois on doit pas
regarder l mn va regarder ce que je vais
appeler z nzl c'est ça va être ça va pas
ça va peut-être la moyenne des x men ça
va être ça est la somme des excès des
bixi / la racine carrée de ncc ccc
possible c'est pas la même chose que m
que la moyenne d'ixelles
je prends éden qui est égal à
[Musique]
définissez aden qui est égal à x1 +6 et
jusqu'à xn / racine carrée de l racine
carrée de hans est plus petit que n donc
on divise par un nombre plus petit que
d'habitude que pour la moyenne donc ça
va faire un peu plus grand que la
moyenne qui est les hellènes du coup va
avoir beaucoup plus on va avoir des
fluctuations d'une manière si d'une
certaine heure si on divise pas pas
racine carrée de haine la somme des xxi
vous pouvez supposer que tout à l'heure
or exposés que les x a jusqu à ixelles
l'idée à espérance nul et moyens et
variance fini
[Musique]
en d
merci sur fait que eden est différent 2
mn du soir si je venais juste l'asean
dxy lycéens plus ghz 2 jusqu'à xn ça
c'est un truc qui qui qui divergeraient
qui seront goffin qui partira dans tous
les sens et qui aura une taille de
l'ordre de racine carrée de m6 / n
je réduis complètement les fluctuations
et là on a la loi dès la loi des grands
moments mais si je fais un truc au
milieu au lieu de faire juste la somme
et au lieu de nous au lieu de diviser
par haine je divise pas un truc et entre
les deux qui racine carrée de haine
à ce moment là je vais avoir un truc
très intéressant qui se passe zen qu'il
est différent de mnz lui va en fait à
l'infini se comporter d'une manière très
agréable
[Musique]
je vais je crains c'est à dire en
probabilités
vers la loi normale
[Musique]
c'est à dire que zeden lui va par contre
converger selon une loi et pas n'importe
quelle loi c'est la loi normale
donc si on suppose de variance égal à 1
rajouter ça comme hypothèse
il
ce paquebot pour y emprunter
zen va converger en probabilité vers la
loi normale n 01
en loi par ne pas contrôler habitées
je confonds toujours les deux
[Musique]
où
pardon donc à convergent probabilité on
doit pardon vers la loi normale n 0 but
qui eut l'idée pour appel ça veut dire
indépendant est identiquement distribués
çà veut dire que ils ont la même loi et
ils sont indépendants et or
[Musique]
ce que prévu de démontrer on va pas
démontré ça donc c'est assez interne
difficile c'est un théorème un peu un
peu miraculeux c'est en tout cas pour
moi on va voir pas mal l'impulsion
derrière ça mais enfin une intuition
derrière ça mais c'est vraiment un
théorème à chaque fois que j'y pense
j'ai j'ai du mal à expliquer et à
trouver une bonne intuition du tout ça
j'ai un peu progressé récemment mais je
vous partage et des progrès mais c'est
un truc assez
il a fallu du temps dans l'histoire pour
que les gens arrivent à le démontrer
c'est un duo
il a été assez intuit et assez
rapidement et rapidement il a été
intuitive et une des démonstrations pas
tout à fait rigoureuses ce qui va
réussir à former et tout ça mais c'est
sans fin il ya deux mois en particulier
la place ont pas mal vu venir le truc
dans des cas simples donc on donc la
démonstration la première démonstration
de ce théorème à 1809
mais dans ses versions plus plus
rigoureuse et plus formalisé mais là il
aura fallu attendre pas mal plus de
temps et il est tellement turing a
démontré la loisne
une version de ces deux du théorème
centrale limite et d'ailleurs c'est ça
il était accusé de plagiat parce qu'il a
démontré quelques quelques années ou
quelques mois après quelqu'un de
quelqu'un d'autre les démontrer donc
c'était dans les années 1930 chose comme
ça
voilà donc quelques remarques sur ses
pas très gros ce que je vais dire donc
c'est ca convergent fait en loi vers une
variable qui quittent qui suit la loi
normale est immense et c'est ça que ça
veut dire
et alors alors je vous pose et le cuit
suivant on veut se rapprocher petit à
petit des intuitions d'air derrière ça
est bon
le cul suivant c'est juste que ça ça me
dit que pour que le théorème centrale
limite soit valide les variables xj
doivent avoir la même distribution
c'est ce que j'ai supposé tel que je les
forme us que c'est une condition
nécessaire d'après vous voulez terme
site central imite il ya plusieurs
variantes en fonction des hypothèses
qu'on fait c'est
[Musique]
voilà la démonstration la plus plus
commune ses théorèmes de lévis en 1922
avec une première preuve rigoureuse de
yap 9 en 1901
les gros outils d'analysé qu'un qu'il
faut déployer
ok pour que le cese ses théorèmes
centrale limite soit validé ce qu'il
faut que les variables soit 2 est la
même distribution
parce que c'est une condition nécessaire
parce qu'elle peut être relâché on peut
avoir des théorèmes du coup plus plus
généraux
[Musique]
et
alors qu'est ce que ça voudrait dire si
le 6 si l'hypothèse sur les xj fait
qu'ils aient les mêmes la même
distribution aussi voir si si si elle
est nécessaire te dire que le théorème
centrale limite s'applique pas non plus
à n'importe quoi il faut vraiment
restreint de son champ d'application
si le théorème centrale limite
s'applique vraiment à n'importe quel
variable xj pourvu qu'elles aient une
moyenne et une variance finie et qu'elle
soit indépendante c'est-à-dire qu'il ya
plein de phénomènes où il ya plein de
contribution comme ça de différents
facteurs
pourvu que s'ils ont suffisamment
indépendant et qui est qu une petite
contribution
le terme centrale limite s'appliquerait
et que du coup en tout cas
approximativement il peut du coup cette
loi normale pourrait apparaître est
vraiment un peu partout donc à beaucoup
d'endroits
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
ce
ok moi ya moins de réponses mois ci à
moins de gens y a pas moins de gens
beaucoup moins dans sa mise à jour en
écoute moi on va dire donc ça va passer
aux réponses néanmoins ok donc csss pour
réponse ressemble à ça et vous penchez
quand même pas mal vert
non l'hypothèse n'est pas nécessaire
donc il faut arriver avec 14 5 7 13
la médiane serait à 3 du coup je est en
effet la consigne de marc et 6,4 points
et c'est vraiment une voix c'est
vraiment ça qui fait que la loi normale
est aussi répandue est un peu parce
qu'elle s'appelle la loi normale c'est
que l anormal apparaît en fait dès qu'
il ya beaucoup de perturbations a dit
yves aléatoire on a plein de petits ji
acquis qui contribuent chacun à modifier
un peu la valeur
cissé existent sont indépendants alors
on commence à voir une loi normale à
paraître
mais la propriétaire importante ici
c'est grâce de l'indépendance par contre
si on perd l'indépendance à ce moment là
on perd en angola le terrain central
imite parce que vous pouvez avoir des
phénomènes de corrélation qui font qu'on
peut avoir des valeurs beaucoup plus
extrêmes par des boucles de rétroaction
donc intuitivement la teom centrale
limite c'est vraiment quand il ya pas
mal de choses qui sont incontrôlables
mais qui sont aussi indépendants qui
font bouger les choses et à ce moment là
de coûts enfin le temps de centrales
limite s'applique beaucoup plus
[Musique]
ok donc alors pourquoi est-ce que le
théorème centrale limite est vrai ont
essayé de repasser à ça fonctionne donc
le
donc le théorème centrale limite il dit
en gros que zen [ __ ] je vais dire que ça
vient c'est à peu près là en fait
aujourd'hui je vais je vais beaucoup
travailler intuition donc pour ce motif
c'est à peu près une loi normale 0 1
lorsque eden est une
et en fixe 1 6l / racine carrée de haine
on va se poser ici que les xxi son idée
pour simplifier avec espérance nul et
variance égal à l'intuition que vous
propose alors des à l'idée c'est que
pour exploiter 7,7 l'indépendance en
particulier ce qui va être important
étudiés c'est quelque chose qui est
l'indépendance et puisque liée à la
multiplication alors là on a des
additions donc sa démultiplication
derrière indépendance
alors que dans cette agression n'a des
additions et du coup on aimerait quelque
chose qui combine un peu l'addition et
la multiplication et au fait il ya un
opérateur qui fait ça très bien donc
c'est l'exponentielle on parti tu es
donc l'exponentielle transforme
l'addition aux multiplications alors que
[Musique]
logarithme féfé dans l'autre sens je
vais envoyer une fiduciaire vidéos de
mickael l'ona qui parle de ça et du coup
l'une des îles et ses deux remplaçants
fin de prendre l'exponentielle de zeden
nous pouvons apprendre exponentielle de
zeden pour pouvoir transformer ces
additions en multiplication
exponentielle de zeden savent être
exponentielle de x1 plus que 6ème /
racine carrée de haine et ça ça va être
aussi la multiplication donc c'est
exponentiel 2 x 1 / racine carrée de
haine fois exponentielle on met des
petits points fois exponentielle de xn /
racine carrée de haine
et ça c'est cool parce que si on prend
maintenant
l'espérance donc lorsqu'on donc vous
voyez maintenant on va essayer
d'exploiter le fait qu'ils sont
indépendants et on peut exploiter le
fait qu'ils soient indépendants en
prenant l'espérance donc là
mathématiquement aussi ce que j'ai écrit
prenons jusque là c'est bien définis
mission regard d'espérance faudrait que
ce soit bien défini normalement
donc a priori c'est pas forcément bien
défini mais on va supposer que c'est
bien défini pas très rigolo très
rigoureux et un autre truc qu'on va
faire c'est on va considérer l'ensemble
de toutes les fonctions exponentielles
on va pas regarder juste cette
expérience est là on va essayer
d'exploiter tout ce qu'on peut savoir
et en fait toutes les exponentielle
toutes les solutions d'éco toutes les
constructions exponentielle fait ça
revient à ajouter ici un facteur
multiplicatif que je vais appeler t je
rajoutais d'été partout l'exponentielle
de thé aden lahj et je sais que ça va
être égal à l'espérance de l'expo n'en
ciel ralenti et demi
c'est la multiplication de tout cela
un expérience elle qui manquent
et ça c'est cool parce que du coup ça
nous fait l'espérance de l'expo n'en
ciel de thé x / un cimetière de haine
puissance elle briguera il reste encore
à calculer ça et à calculer ça
mais ça lui donne une bonne idée de ses
exploite bien les bonnes preuves les
propriétés des objets qu'on va étudier
je proposais de calculer l'espérance de
puissance des z
en supposant que a depuis une loi
normale
une loi normale ça veut dire que ça va
être l'espérance 2e puissance dz fois
pour poser d'un partenaire fois zzz où
elle faisait deux années et la fonction
de densité de la loi normale sauf que ma
fonction densité de normal c'est un sur
racine carrée de tout sur moi
z car est divisé par deux dz
mais ça ça se calcule du coup c'est
souffert assure racine carrée de tau x
intégrale de exponentielle de moi z 2
sur 2 plus d aide t elle est là la
suisse et que on connaît un début de
deux carrés et on va essayer d'écrire ça
du coup de la forme
z - tu es au carré divisé par deux à
quatre mois
et pour que ça soit le cas on voit que
c'est la forme canonique
donc si on développe on voit bien qu'on
a le moins m² sur deux qui apparaît
puisque le terme croisé qui sera bien
plus des aides mais on va avoir un terme
- thé carrés sur deux en plus et du coup
pour l'annuler il faut rajouter tkr est
divisé par deux donc là on a une égalité
et à ce moment là on voit que ça c'est
égal insu racine carrée de thau
intégrale de la puissance - z ce monte
au carré sur deux plus des carrés sur
deux des aides alors l'expérience yale
d'une somme on peut voir que c'est une
chose que
aux puissances tekkari divisé par deux
et ça on peut le sortir de l'intégrale
puisque ça ne dépend pas de z
et là on peut et pour cette partie là en
fait
en fait on reconnaît en fait une loi
normale qui a été décalée de tas de thé
en tout cas on peut faire le changement
de variables je posais eu est égal à z
montée du coût à des huées et égale à
des aides et du coup ça nous fait en
puissance des carrés sur deux sur racine
carrée de thau fois l'intégrale de
puissance - uqar et sur 2 des u
il en fait ça c'est c'est l'intégrale de
enfin sur les enfants si je regarde
plutôt ça ça revient à intégrer la loi
la loi normale surtout terre donc c'est
la probabilité d'une valeur dans air et
du coup c'est égal à 1
donc c'est égal à la puissance des
carrés sur deux ok donc ça c'est juste
un résultat intéressant à noter
ce qui ressort de cette analyse c'est
que donc si on regarde l'espérance 2e
puissance tzen ça on a vu que c'est
l'espérance de puissance tx10 et pas
racine carrée de haine puissance n est
la question qu'on se pose c'est lorsque
est née très grand est ce que ça va
donner la même chose que la loi normale
pour la loi normale
on sait que ça c'est égal à une
puissance tkr est divisé par deux donc
voilà la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que ça ça temps ça pour limite ça
lorsque l on tend vers l'infini
alors avant des plus loin ont posé le
huitième cuisent qui arrivait d'un peu
de technique aussi
donc supposons donc là j'ai fait le
calcul pour une loi normale centre et
standards moyenne égale à zéro et par
expérience égale à zéro et l'écart type
égal à 1
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le cas
général donc le
[Musique]
doc est donc le quiz le huitième cuisse
et suivants on suppose maintenant on a
une loi normale
donc il ya une mois donc musset
l'espérance de loi normale
et si m'a caressé la variance la loi
normale donc une autre façon de l'écrire
c'est de dire que x est égal à mu plus
sigma z
e
[Musique]
pensez vous avoir tous perdu là
donc on prend une loi normale qui est
cette fois n'est pas centré et on va
calculer aussi cette quantité qui semble
vraiment intéressante qui est
l'espérance 2e puissance thé xx c'est de
l'avoir moyen ce que je prends puissance
des x et c'est intéressant parce que
parce que comme on l'a vu ça permette
d'exploiter l'indépendance entre
différentes variables lorsqu'elles sont
additionnés elle permet de transformer
l'addition un multiplication et ensuite
avec l'indépendance de transformer la
musique de l'espérance d'une mutilation
d'espérance en la multiplication des
espérances et on a vu que pour une loi
normale centre et c'est ça fait le
puissant cet écart est divisé par deux
est ce que si je prends une loi normale
de son général
[Musique]
est-ce que ça ça vous paraît aussi une
façon de résoudre le problème c'est de
faire le calcul ça le calcul marche bien
[Musique]
td façon plus intelligente d'y arriver
il pose moi
[Musique]
ok passer aux résultats donc eu 23
réponse ça diminue pas mal 24 maintenant
donc 9 à 12 9 à 12 ans et entre sept et
huit la réponse médiane bon on va dire
on va dire 8 et donc la réponse était
oui donc
marquis 8 10 à 24 ans tout va bien
l'impression qu'il ya une fraction plus
important que d'habitude de
l'anticyclone est bien ça se montre que
dans les commentaires alors pourquoi on
y voit en fait le lieu enfin le calcul
direct en fait ce qu'on peut remarquer
c'est que si je regarde moi je devrais
appeler ça plutôt que j'ai déjà des x un
peu partout mais si je regarde y est
égal à mu plus sigma z
donc si je prends maintenant l'espérance
2e puissance tnt y basse à fait puisque
l'espérance de puissance mu puce sigma z
donc c'est égal donc les l'espérance
l'exponentielle d'une somme c'est le
produisent et des exponentielle donc
c'est l'espérance de puissance mu fois
puissance sigma z/os puissance musset
une constante qui dépend pas avec qui
qui n'est pas aléatoire qui est une
constante et donc on peut la sortir de
l'espérance donc ça nous fait oublier le
tbt par toi donc là le puissance temu
peut sortir 900 stemi fois l'espérance
de puissance tessinoise aide et là
l'astuce c'est de voir qu'on peut mettre
tes fois sigma entre parenthèses et
considérer que c'est ça la variable
ici
et
du coup on a finalement là la même
expression on peut écrire on peut
remplacer en fait cette expression la
part où on peut remplacer t partait
sigma et du coup ça nous fait de
puissance temu de puissance
donc là on a du thé sigma au carré
divisé par deux et donc ça c'est égal à
eux puissance temu plus produit des
exponentielle c'est la somme des
expériences elle de l'asean tessi de
macquarie / de décarie c'est moi qui lui
ai parlé et ça c'est vraiment cool comme
résultat parce que ça va nous permettre
de montrer une propriété assez
remarquable de de la loi normale
je t'ai de passer un texte en ce sens
qui nous dit que si x et y sont
indépendants et suivent des lois
normales alors x plus y aussi
bon en fait c'était vrai il est valable
même 6 y sont ne sont pas indépendants
ce qui est remarquable mais dans
d'autres cas on peut le remarquer pour
le cas où x et greg sont indépendants
c'est un théorème en gros ce théorème
dit que la loi normale est stable par
addition en tout cas indépendante
puisque ne pensez pas nécessaire mais
aujourd'hui vous pouvez juste de fait
dans le cas où x et y sont indépendants
pourquoi ben en fait il suffit de
calculer
ça peut être une démonstration ultra
rigoureuse ça ne manque pas grand chose
pour l'heure une rigoureuse mais ça peut
être une démonstration rigoureuse mais
il est la démonstration c'est de
regarder ce terme donc les l'espérance
de puissance thé xx xx plus y quand ce
terme se se comporte
si je regarde l'espérance de puissance
thé xx plus y bat ça je sais que c'est
donc c
ça je sais que c'est l'espérance de thé
x 2 plus 2 exponentielle de thé xx
exponentielle de thé y est salée
en fait je n'aime pas le et là ce que je
vais utiliser c'est l'indépendance
encore une fois on va utiliser
dépendance pour séparer de l'espérance
donc x est indépendant de y
c'est à dire qu'aussi aux puissances thé
xx va être indépendante de puissance
tout y est comme ils sont indépendants
et l'espérance du produit et le produit
des espérances et donc ça ça va être
égal à l'espérance de puissance thé xx x
l'espérance de la puissante et y
et ensuite
bon on connaît donc supposons que x soit
une loi normale de paramètres mix sigma
x regard et et y tinois normal de
paramètres mu grecque
cima y en carré
montrer que x plus y suit une loi
normale de paramètres muzzix plus mme y
sigma x carré plus s'y met y hockey
[Musique]
et comment montrer ça on va exploiter
maintenant ce qu'on vient de démontrer
pour les lois normales et du coup
l'espérance de puissance thé xx on a vu
que c'était égal à
et puissance des mues x plus si des
carrés si mike ce qu'a réalisé par lh2
et l'expert et l'espérance de y ce c'est
la même chose pour y
donc ça fait d expression un peu un peu
moche comme ça mais on peut du coup les
regrouper par l export la musculation
etc spécial c'est une somme peut-être
l'écrire plus tôt comme ça sera plus
clair du coup on a ça
et on peut regrouper les musiques c'est
mieux y est simon hix carré ici malgré
carré et ça nous donne l'exponentielle
de tmx puisse plus y plus déclaré
6/4 et plus il y carré tout divisé par
deux
et
alors comme ça ça peut paraître moche
en fait on voit bien apparaître le mix
plus me y est on voit bien apparaître de
sigma x carré puce sigma y carré et du
coup on voit que l'espérance 2e
puissance thé xx plus y as exactement la
forme qu'on attendrait d'une loi normale
de paramètres me x plus nous y est
sigma ex carré plus il va y carré et
documents créés un peu un petit dernier
argument pour dire que si on a la bonne
forme
c'est qu'on est forcément une loi
normale donc ça ça peut démontrer aussi
c'est un peu plus galère je peux le
faire ici mais en plus il ya des façons
plus élégante de le faire mais c'est un
peu ça le message clé c'est que dans
cette en fait expérience 2e puissance t
fois les la variable aléatoire on en
fait toute l'information nécessaire pour
connaître cette variable aléatoire et ce
qui est génial avec cette forme c'est
que c'est quelque chose qui est très
propice à ce qui est très fin qui est
très liée à l'addition et à
l'indépendance ça se marie bien donc
c'est une bonne façon d'étudier
[Musique]
des variables qui s'additionnent de
manière indépendante
[Musique]
en fait ça va être vraiment la clé 2
de l'intuition que j'aimerais donner de
la variable des variables 1 2 du tram
centrale limite c'est que lorsqu'on
additionne plein de petites variable
aléatoire indépendante
on retrouve quelque chose qui est de la
forme puissance
t pour la fois une moyenne plus d'écart
et fois une variance divisé par deux et
en particulier si on prend des variables
centre et oublier le mix puisse me
grecque
on aura quelque chose à forme t carré
fois une variance divisé par deux et
donc ça ça correspond un peu haut vol m
certains même approximatif
même si on fait ça se formalise c'est
d'essayer de rester peu près simple
aujourd'hui si je pense que j'ai pas
trop ici vous reste posée que x et à
décentrer et variance unis et tarik
également
on n'en trouve que
et la quantité que vous propose
d'étudier maintenance et c'est ce
qu'elle est c'est celle qui apparaît
lorsqu'on faisait les calculs donc tout
à l'heure on avait vu on avait vu ça qui
fait intervenir en particulier ces
quantités là l'été x / racine carrée de
n est pas ce qu'on va voir maintenant
c'est que c'est et x / racine carrée de
haine en fait il lorsque n est grand il
se comporte bien dans le sens où ils
vont ressembler à une loi normale avec
très peu de c'est à peu près une loi
nome normal mon sens où ça va être à peu
près e puissance
techar est divisé par 2 n
notamment lorsque lorsque n tend vers
l'infini
même plus précisément
plus précisément c'est pas tout à fait
précis mais c'est plus précisément corps
t / racine carrée de haine est très
petit demorand
[Musique]
donc là on va se poser que l'espérance
est une variable d'espérance nul et de
variance 1 et l'idée c'est que donc donc
ça se formalise en mai
jusqu'à 17 cette version-là l'espérance
de puissance t x / racine carrée et de
haine ressemble à ce qu'on aurait 6 x
était une loi normale plutôt x10 est pas
racine carrée dunn était une loi normale
c'est un peu l'intuition clé c'est que
lorsqu'on prend entre vent et qu'on
regarde et du coup on restreint la
valeur de 2 x d'une certaine manière à
ce moment-là x ressemble à une loi
normale pas dans n'importe quel sens
dans un sens qui est donnée par parcelle
ce calcul de puissance des xkrs de
l'espérance de puissance tx7 autre façon
de voir les probabilités d'une certaine
manière où les variables ricort est donc
la raison de cela
la raison de cela c'est que ça viendra
en fait l'une d'une approximation qui
est que e puissance x c'est à peu près
égal à 1 + x et on va y arriver plus x
car est divisé par deux camps
x absolue et x est très petit
quand il sait très petit alors là c'est
la procréation qui optent 106 donc
s'appelle un développement limité qui
qui est égal à peu près à la un pays x +
6 carrés sur deux on peut voir ça
graphiquement
de puissance x ça ressemble à ça et si
on regarde un +6 déjà une bonne
approximation et donner une couleur et
si en plus on rajoute x car est divisé
par deux là on a vraiment une bonne
approximation lacombe orange colle
vraiment bien à la courbe bleue se
justifie par le développement limité et
du coup ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que si je regarde maintenant
l'espérance 2e puissance tx10 et pas
racine carrée de haine
donc ça c'est approximativement égale
alors là le seul c'est vraiment le
approximativement égale il faudrait
vraiment entrer dans les détails parce
que c'est pas si simple mais l'idée
c'est que si sienne est très très grand
alors tx10 et pas racine carrée de n est
vraiment petit que si elle est très très
grand du coup on peut utiliser cette
approximation du coup on peut dire que
c'est à peu près l'espérance 2 1 + t x
lisez pas racine carrée de haine
plus tu es déclaré x car est divisé par
2 n j'ai vraiment impliqué à formule du
dessus avec un petit hic c'est et
galatée 30x disait pas racine carrée de
haine et ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que vu que l'espérance d'une somme
est la somme des espérances on va
pouvoir transformer sa peau ne venez pas
à peu près égale à sept en liga ça va
être égal à donc bon je vais écrire
entièrement espérances de 1
l'espérance d'un truc con sans cesser de
trucs constant plus le thé racine carrée
de haine il dépend pas il est constant
fin il et déterministe du coup on peut
le sortir vous savez tes racines carrées
de haine espérances de x
plus à cet écart est divisé par 2 n
espérances de x carré or on a vu dans
prennent aux hypothèses que ça c'est
égal à zéro et ça c'est égal à 1
du coup on obtient un plus
donc ça ça s'annule il reste plus que ça
du tkr est divisé par 2 n
et il se trouve que ça c'est aussi égale
donc si on prend juste les deux premiers
termes si on oublie ce terme n'a vu que
aussi aux 6 et d'approximations là et du
coup un peu cet écart est divisé par 2 n
on peut remplacer x par t -k rédigé par
deux n du coup c'est aussi à peu près
égale à e puissance
tekkari / 2 n mais
du coup du coup on a bien
l'approximation dont je vous ai parlé
ici et ça se dire qu'on est vraiment pas
loin parce que on avait vu ce qu'ils
book on avait vu cette expression l'
expression l'homme et du coup on voit
que espérances de pau puissance tz1 n
ça c'est égal à l'espérance de puissance
tx10 visé par racine carrée de haine
étoiles puissance n est du coup d'après
ce qu'on a là ça serait à peu près
égales dans ce que lorsque n est grand
temps vers l'infini à eux aux puissances
tkr est divisé par 2 n le tout appuyé
sont saines et havas ont un peu magique
ça c'est aux puissants cet écart est
divisé par deux voir ça c'est vraiment
le truc associé à la loi normale centre
et dz et du coup on à l'approximation
que si on regarde la variable aléatoire
zen
mais avec cette espérance de puissance
tzen cette autre façon de regarder les
variables at war qui est beaucoup plus
qu'ils se marient beaucoup plus avec
l'indépendance et l'addition
on voit que option stereden quinzaine et
finalement similaire à z en ce sens et
donc ça c'est c'est pas tout à fait la
démonstration la plus classique
pourquoi parce que le problème c'est que
ces termes là en fait ce ne sont pas
très bien défini parce que en
particulier ces termes là parce qu'on
peut avoir déçu surtout si l'enfant il
se peut avoir une trop grande variations
extrêmes notamment si on a des lois de
puissance ces termes là il ya trop de
vague de cas de valloire extreme 2 x
pour que ça se soit un nombre fini
vous imaginez on prend aux puissances
fois ce nombre est du coup c'est donc
quand il prend des valeurs assez grande
ça fait démontré très grand il ça peut
diverger et du coup en pratique le truc
qui marche beaucoup mieux d'un point de
vue mathématique
parce que là c'est un peu des
raisonnements qui peuvent être formalisé
mais il ya besoin cam d'hypothèses assez
forte pour que tout marche comme i comme
il faut en pratique au lieu d'utiliser
directement ça que l'astuce c'est du
d'étudier en fait l'ex potentiel 2e
puissance idz des aliens par exemple et
puis mon l'espérance de puissance ilité
z
et l'espérance de puissance i&t x /
racine carrée de l'aisne
donc on rajoute le nombre imaginaire y
ait en fait ça ça ça simplifie beaucoup
les choses parce que ces quantités
seront toujours bien défini pourquoi
parce que de puissance yz quel que soit
valoir deux aides pour vu que z prennent
ils des valeurs réelles et c'est ce
qu'on étudie si l'option cité z restera
sur cercle unité ne sera quelque part
ici ou là et du coup ces quantités là
sont des moyennes de points qui sont
toujours à distance 1 2 0 qui sont
toujours borné du comprend des moyennes
sur des valeurs borné et on n'a pas ces
problèmes l'extrême est du coup ça
marche très très bien
et en gros toute la preuve que j'ai
écrite là peuvent être rendus très
facilement rigoureuse avec tout ça donc
ça c'est bon plan imagine complexe et en
fait tout ça aussi c'est aussi très lié
à transformée de fourier vous avez sont
peut-être déjà entendu parler en effet
si je regarde exponentielle deux
puissances ite x on va dire
ben en fait formellement ça s'écrit
l'intégrale sur air de puissance it et
xfx x dx ce qui est en gros la
transformée de fourier de fx haute et
pourtant en gros parce qu'elles
transforment de foyers souvent il ya des
constantes de normalisation qui
apparaissent en fait bizarrement l'a
transformée de fourier les nombres
complexes sont super utile pour
comprendre la loi normale c'est-à-dire
l'addition de variables indépendantes
c'est assez fou qui se lire
[Musique]
ça marche aussi bien c'est un truc qui
me qui m'a longtemps perturbé à dire moi
qui me perturbe encore pourquoi pourquoi
est ce que pour comprendre la loi
normale on a besoin d'eux l'a
transformée de fourier des variables des
dénombre imaginaire ça marche
les maths c'est fou qu on approche de la
fin un petit dati hélas deux crises en
tous cas je sais pas si ça a aidé mais
aujourd'hui en tout cas avec c'est cette
approche là j'essaie de donner un peu
plus intuitif comment est ce que on aura
un jour elle pu découvrir une preuve moi
même du terme central imite géo que
pendant longtemps je me suis dit bon bah
je le prend pour acquis
je ne peux pas en dire plus là avec ses
preuves là je consomme dire que
peut-être que si j'avais beaucoup a
fléchi et que tu essaies travail
j'aurais peut-être pu le trouver en me
disant on m'a fait transformer fait
qu'exploiter l'indépendance du coup faut
y associer une tradition la
multiplication est bon si on prend le
cas simple où tout marche bien avec ces
deux puissances thé xx ça a l'air de
bien marcher et se trouve que si on
rajoute les mondes imaginaires tout est
borné
peut-être que j'aurais pu le trouver
c'est loin d'être gagné mais peut-être
que ouais ça parle peu moins magique en
disant tout ça je dois si ça vous pas un
peu moins magique en disant tout sauf
peut-être que j'aurais pu y penser
vous aussi en tout cas il aura fallu des
des années des siècles entre les
premiers travaux de fermat et pascal
jusqu'au preuve des années du début du
20ème siècle pour pour comprendre tout
ça et le rendre rigoureux est formel
c'est
les maths ça se construit pas en un jour
on trouve des liens entre des trucs
incroyables et seulement la loi normale
c'est ça fait partie de ces choses
[Musique]
bizarrement peuvent être comprises avec
des maths qui sont plus profonds cuse
élégante mais aussi moins moins
intuitive de prime abord
[Musique]
la main j'ai déjà donné la réponse à
cette crise c'est pas sérieux pas trop
vite
bon ben ça me permet de tester si vous
avez bien suivi
tout variable à toi x la fonction doit
on appelle ça la fonction
caractéristiques
donc c'est une fonction qui dépend de s
souvent elle est notée voir fides un
fils de so2 tu es là quand vous jouez
pas mal utilisé
donc pour tout variable aléatoire cette
fonction de caractéristiques est bien
défini pour tous variable aléatoire au
réel est bien défini
et
[Musique]
il
logiciel de traitement de texte
s'appelle ya writer
donc j'utilise d'ordinaire beaucoup plus
pour écrire mes scripts s'écoule truc
avec la tech
[Musique]
bon il ya plus beaucoup de réponses
voilà peut-être un peu vite c'est du
coup mais il ya 13 réponse 6,7
la médiane est ici huit manches et pour
le oui la réponse en effet et wind par
les pluies d'hier il 4 goals et la
raison c'est que
comme j'ai déjà dit c'est que bon
techniquement si vous transformez de
foyers une fonction bornes et
intégrables dans la raison intuitive
c'est que le l'espérance
depuis ty et de puissance eux y ait 6 et
7 6 et une valeur réelle sera toujours
bornes et sera toujours là et on prend
des moyennes valeurs bornes et donc on
peut pas avoir deux cas où ça va dit
vergeer infinie on peut prouver que x et
mesurables c'est peut-être ça qui a
coincé
le dernier truc
enfin un truc dernier truc qui ont envie
de parler avant de parler aux derniers
cuisent c'est de ce qui se passe en
pratique pour des données fini parce que
le le théorème centrale limite il a le
gros désavantage d'être quelque chose
d'à symptomatique le théorème de
centrale limite est valable à l'infini
et du coup il ne nous dit pas forcément
grand chose de ce qui se passe pour des
données fini si on a seulement un
milliard de variables là qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire à propos de ces variables en
partie qui est ce qu'on peut dire de la
queue de distribution est ce que ça se
ressent bien une loi normale comme il
faut et il ya un truc très cool pour
étudier ce cas qui est une égalité deux
oeuvres de deux tiers font les
inégalités de concentration tout son
général en particulier
bon aujourd'hui on va juste voir les
parler de l'inégalité procédure
et
je
cher 9
sur le texte
l'inégalité de terre-neuve
donc l'idée de lier t2 chernoff donc en
fait c'est de reprendre le l'inégalité
de markov on a vu donc je vais d'abord
rappelé l'illégalité de markov
mais pour un truc pour des deux des
valeurs très extrêmes en un sens l'unité
de markov a dit que non
[Musique]
oh
l'inégalité de markov on avait vu un anr
fouace et vin plutôt inégalités de
terre-neuve a appliqué la même chose
mais une façon exponentielle et façon de
voir ça c'est que moi je vais écrire la
preuve directement la probité que x soit
supérieur égale acté
ça c'est égal à la probabilité que
puissance t x soit supérieure et gala
puissance téa puisque la fonction
il y était de markov faille que x soit
positif je mets des valeurs absolues
pour que ce soit pour tout x line
galliano cardin vous je vous laisse
regarder les cas où x est plus grand que
ras et basse il s'est super bien les
gars assis et selon six absences thé xx
est plus grand que puissance t as pas ce
que font ces expériences est allée
croissante et là je vais appliquer je
peux appliquer de l'égalité de markov en
remarquant que puissance thé xx est
forcément positif et du coup ça me dit
que ça ça va être plus petit que
puissance - tu es à voile espérances de
puissance t x
[Musique]
donc ça c'est une égalité de 2-2 qui dit
que ouais en gros le la probabilité
d'avoir des cas extrêmes
si j'arrive à dire que l'ex potentiel
que l'espérance de l'expérience yale 2x
vtx est faible alors je peux dire que ça
ça va être très petit cd croître
exponentiellement
donc c'est ça reporte problème à estimer
l'espérance de puissance des x et ça
c'est intéressant pour des dans des cas
où on arrive assez bien estimé cela et
c'est le cas de l'addition de variables
indépendantes
ça va nous amener à l'inégalité de
hunting et la manière d'en tourner ton
va y avait seulement on va se poser que
amoah place de x ici je vais prendre moi
je vais prendre la somme des xxi comme
ils fondent l'égalité 2 2
vous vous rappelez s la somme des xxi
et
[Musique]
excellent et on va supposer que les
variables sont centrés aussi ça
simplifier les calculs et je suppose et
qu'elle soit indépendante
et euh je suppose et des autres et
maintenant aussi on va supposer qu'ils
également que valoir dans le moins 1
donc l'idée c'est qu'on va petit big man
et étudier ce qui se passe quand on
lance une pièce on va dire qu'on marque
plus
1 lorsque c'est ça tombe sur piles est
moindre quand ça tombe sur surface est
ce qu'on a envie de dire c'est que le
nombre de piles sera très proche d'un an
et demi en moyenne 20 la moyenne des
piles sera très proche de 1 2 me donc
s'il y a annoncé de haine sur deux et
que l'erreur sera proportionnée racine
carrée de haine mais si on écrit
l'erreur comme p x racine carrée de n24
fois racing jeunes alors qu'angers
augmente tout cas la probabilité des cas
extrêmes va décroître exponentiellement
avec car c'est un peu l'idée de la
preuve alors pour démontrer sa je pense
passer à ce qu'on m'avait prêté que x
fois supérieure et gala à thé
puissance xt
ok donc pour fait on voit on l'appliqué
as plutôt qu'à x
oh là là là
on va t'en pisé masse quelques heures
tournant dit
juste rappelé chernoff
on lui quelque intermédiaire donc limité
de tarnow n oublie ça et je remplace et
x par s du coup maintenant le grand défi
c'est essayer de dire pourquoi
est-ce-que exponentielle de puissance ts
ne peut pas être si grand que ça et
après on va optimiser la valeur de t
pour dire que terme de droite est
vraiment vraiment faible si choisi la
bonne valeur de t ça a été un peu ça le
plan soit pour montrer que les valeurs
extrêmes lorsqu'on ajoute des variables
aléatoires un nombre fini devant
l'abattoir les valeurs extrêmes restent
très très peu probable et donc pour
arriver à faire ça on va regarder
exponentielle d'options cts moi c'est
quelque chose qu'on a pas mal déjà
étudiés ont lancé les calculs en eau
sc
[Musique]
et
bon
est ce assez assomme dxy l'exponentielle
le rectorat les calculs
essayant de sauter un peu et calcule en
utilisant gaulle à l'indépendance comme
on l'a déjà fait on peut montrer que
l'expérience yale de l'espérance de
puissance ts va être égal à l'est
l'espérance de deux puissances tx2 tout
à la puissance n est pas ce qu'on peut
remarquez c'est que si je prends une
variable x qui est dans au moins un an
en fait je vais même prendre le car un
cas plus simple pour illustrer on va
prendre le cas où les x y sont égales à
-1 avec probabilité probabilité 1/2 et
xxi est égal à 1 avec probité en 2000 la
la je prends une des variables
aléatoires en grossissant le pil pile ou
face
je marque plus ainsi sa tombe sur piles
et moins ainsi sa tombe surface et ont
essayé de voir quel est l'écart entre le
monde de piles et de face et dans ce
chaos puissance exponentielle de la
puissance des x bats ça va être égal à
si je regarde l'ex la puissance et x
bah ça avec probabilité 1/2 x est égal à
à -20 ans donc ça fait dix ans - t et
avec probabilité 1/2
ça fait deux puissances t
et alors c'est un peu plus compliqué de
mettre cette expression là à la
puissance n
on va essayer de simplifier de trouver
de montrer qu'ils avaient plus petit
qu'un autre truc et pour cela peut
essayer de tracer ça si je trace
puissance x plus de puissance x
le tout divisé par deux et
on peut s'en rendre compte que c'est
plus petit que que puissant 6/4 et
divisé par deux donc on peut le
démontrer formellement mais a battu
dimanche à l'infini puissant site carrés
sur deux ça croît beaucoup plus vite
vers l'infini parce qu'il ya un hic ce
carré où il ya de verdun x ou dans mon x
et l'autre truc c'est qu'on voit que
localement autour de 1
bah c'est cette france à avoir les mêmes
termes d'ordre le même développement de
taylor aux deux premiers ordres pour que
ça vous fout ça fait en plus zéro + x
car est divisé par deux je vais être à
saint pie x car est divisé par deux on
voit que c'est c'est en jean à tout ça
c'est la même approximation de premier
ordre mais x carré croix puis 8
et du coup à si on revient à ce qu'on
écrivait
du coup puissance thé xx on sait que
c'est inférieur à 2 puissances techar
est divisée par deux alors ça c'est
beaucoup plus facile de le mettre à la
puissance n ça veut dire que du coup on
a une borne surpuissance ts qui va être
plus petit que puissance nt carré divisé
par deux
et ça c'est intéressant parce que du
coup on peut appliquer on peut mettre ça
dans la borne de tarnow et voir que du
coup dans la borne de terre-neuve
on a
la probabilité que la somme soit plus
grande
tu as
va être inférieure de puissance - ta1
puissance entheca rédigé par deux
[Musique]
et donc ça on peut le rake hier comme
l'exponentielle de moin té à plus
intacte et qu'a réalisé par deux
donc on retrouve encore toujours est
encore et toujours en fait d'aider des
formulations assez similaire ccc
correspond aux trucs de l'exposant ciel
de la loi normale et l'avantagent cette
fois c'est que enfin là ce qu'on peut
faire maintenant c'est optimiser la
valeur de t pour laquelle la valeur
enfin le terme de droite est le plus
petit possible parce que ça on sait que
c'est vrai pour tout et est donc c'est
vrai lorsque tu es très très grand de
façon évidente est ce que le mtq arrive
au compte des valeurs très très grande
et si on optimise un peu la valeur de t
pour optimiser la valeur de t bonds il
faut optimiser ce cas à droite et on
peut prendre la dérive et de juste de
cette expression par rapport à t il on
voit que cet animal pour tes est égal à
ah ah / n 6 voteront pas à 10 et pas n
est plus facile de faire les calculs sur
ce qu'est sur un support cassure des
textes des 10 et à 10 et parraine ça me
fait du akkar et / n
/
donc là on va voir du akkar et qui va
paraître mais alors du n 2 n ça nous
fait ça et donc ça se simplifient et ça
nous fait juste du mois
c'est vraiment le truc c'est un des
trucs les moins pédagogique que j avais
on obtient cette équation à la fin qui
est une équation assez assez c'est
génial quand on y réfléchit donc ça
donne même envie de remplacer à part
donc cette fois on va poser à est égal à
quatre fois à 5/4 et de haine
si je mets cas racine carrée de haine à
la place de à la joie alors qu'à racine
carrée de l'aisne
j'avoue avoir du cas carré fois n 10 et
parraine ok ça va ça nul et donc si
géoméga as macquarie de haine
ça va me faire ma place
quelques arrêts disait paul bref ça ces
inégalités de holding en fait c'est un
cas particulier de l'île a été de
holding qui est capable de généraliser
ce résultat à dos d'autres lois de
probabilité par dante ou quand x y sont
justes entre -1 et 1 et on peut même
généralisée ça ce qu'on appelle des les
distractions sugo sienne mais c'est
cette inégalité là en tout cas elle
c'est quelque chose de vraiment utile en
pratique dans beaucoup de modèles
notamment machine learning
on va supposer plus ou moins que les
données sont assez indépendante donc que
quelque chose dedans et donner à ces
indépendants donc c'est un modèle
génératif et à partir de ça on peut
montrer à essayer de montrer que pour
tout échantillon angoy en gros pour la
plupart du temps ça va bien marcher et
quand on dit la plupart du temps on
entend souvent avec une probabilité est
grande ou cette probabilité s'appuie sur
l'hypothèse d'indépendance kick et turcs
les mais ça permet de dire que cette
probabilité que quelque chose se passe
mal typiquement quelque chose de boxe va
mal se passer si parce qu'on a estimé
ces cartes beaucoup trop de ce à quoi il
faut s'attendre mais la priorité que ça
s'écarte beaucoup trop à plus de cas
écart-type une certaine manière la
probité que ça s'écarte à plus de kayes
car type décroît et souvent
exponentiellement éducation nationale
independence donc sous un thème une
dépendance sous l'hypothèse indépendance
on arrive souvent à vos avoir des
garanties sur le fait que les cas
extrêmes sont exponentiellement rares ce
qui nous permet d'avoir pas mal de
garanties sur dire que en pratique ça a
bien marché donc c'est cette inégalité
de housing qui est vraiment critique ans
dans beaucoup de preuves en théorie du
machine learning pour montrer que les
choses ont bien fonctionné mais
j'insiste aussi sur le fait que ça
dépend beaucoup de l'hypothèse
d'indépendance qui dans beaucoup de cas
pratiques
ne s'applique pas si on n'a pas
l'indépendance et ben en argot n'a pas
la loi des grands nombres et du coup on
n'a pas le terme sont très limités tout
ça et les choses peuvent mal que peuvent
mal tourner j'espère que c'était un peu
fouillis mais j'espère que vous voyez un
peu l'intuition est en tout cas les
idées de preuve à chaque fois c'est de
passer en c'est exponentiel de thé xx
pour comprendre la variable x notamment
pour ce qui est des de l'indépendance et
de l'addition entre plusieurs variables
x x y c'est une astuce qui marche
vraiment bien qui permet de rien de bien
comprendre la loi des grands nombres et
en particulier ses déviations de la
moyenne
et pour finir je veux finir avec un
dernier quiz qui je crois est écrit de
façon horrible on va voir ce que ça va
donner
ouais donc donc ça c'est une inégalité
de concentration mais en fait il ya
d'autres inégalités de concentration de
dire quelque chose peuvent pas trop mal
tourné ou la probité de cas extrêmes est
vraiment exponentiellement rares sous
hypothèse d'indépendance et l'addition
de plein de petites et armengaud
et la raison pour laquelle mon temps je
voulais vraiment c'est ça plus finir ses
commentaires à sa lecture de réécrire sa
vie
il
bon pour cette question je m'attends pas
à ce que vous vous trouviez la réponse
comme ça mais si vous pouvez avoir une
intuition
[Musique]
et
aps lorson
[Musique]
donc si si je prends des variables x12
kxl aléatoire et indépendante a valeur
de 0,1
je suppose pas forcément occasions même
même distribution
j'appelle s lorson la somme des xxi mu
l'espérance de hesse et je prends des
valeurs lambda entre 0 et racine carrée
de vue alors donc voilà la question je
vous demande c'est est ce qu'on peut
garantir que s sera toujours la priorité
que s soit angot égal à mu puce lambda
racine kane est devenu plus ou moins
enfantin une valeur qui est proche de sa
un prêt est ce que la probabilité de sa
est forcément plus petite que puissante
- lambda carré / 3 / e
racine carrée de pi / fois mieux est-ce
que vous pensez que ça c'est vrai ou pas
quels sont vos intuitions par rapport à
ça donc c'est dire que donc très
variables at war jeu
la question c'est à quel point ça
s'écarte de menu donc on s'attend que la
moyenne des xxi voilà la somme des xxi
soit égale s soit proche de sa moyenne
comme c'est une somme de plaintes
variable aléatoire indépendante s'attend
à ce que racine carrée de mu c'est un
bon ordre de grandeur pour la pour les
cartes ippon gros et ce que je dis c'est
que ça s'éloigne de lambda fois l'écart
type gros c'est pas tout à fait car type
s'est produite et que ça se trouve dans
une à peu près à ça à une variable
aléatoire près j'ai envie de dire enfin
là c'est pas très clair ce que dit la
priorité que ça s'écarte de mu de lambda
fois racine carrée devenu de lambda
foire espèce de proxy de l'écart type
mais pas avant le garde pas uniquement
les valeurs extrêmes et et valeurs
pacy extrêmement gros massa serait plus
petit que puissant smaland dakar et / 3
/ la racine carrée de pie x mue donc
racine carrée de mula on voit l'écart
type pierre apparaît en bas âge ou d un
dominateur à nouveau qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ça ce que vous pensez que
c'est plutôt vrai plutôt faut cesser la
dernière question après ça je vous
libère presque selon live à nouveau oui
à 9 réponses on peut passer à 10 je suis
donné
[Musique]
et puis l'autre truc que je voulais dire
c'est rcg par ed chernoff et de 10000 ya
encore d'autres inégalités qui dit des
soie des capes plus précis donc à raison
que les inégalités de perdre steintz un
peu plus précise pour le cas où où on
sait plus de choses sur les x y ou je
crois qu'ils peuvent prendre uniquement
des valeurs moins ou en classe comme ça
et aussi non il ya des inégalités pour
des martingales ou des supers martingale
donc une super martingale c'est un peu
une courbe qui varient au cours du temps
mais on sait que en espérant ça va être
décroître sûreté nationale et à la
question c'est est ce qu'on se pose
c'est quelle sont les priorités des cas
extrêmes que ça que ça augmente
radicalement intuitivement à veut dire
que c'est très faible parce que déjà
cinq ans puisse aller à décroître il est
des réflexions et des théorèmes ton peut
prouver sur en fonction des hypothèses à
chaque fois et sur les valeurs extrêmes
que ça peut attendre
ok bon passé en réponse au quizz vous
avez dit réponses et vous êtes très
proche de 5
pas mal d'incertitudes et a quand même
un qui est sûr de lui la console wii
avec 9
si je prends la médiane bas ségala 5 la
médiane et la réponse en fait à se
cuisent ou peut-être entre 5 et 6 dans
ces cinq est en fait mon parti
d'histoire ça c'est une conjecture que
j'ai mise donc je ne connais pas avait
il ya quatre ans mais toujours pas la
réponse ici à des gens qui sont motivés
par un prof de maths à la cg j'avais
posté ça sur matt stava exxon que à un
certain moment parce que ça m'aurait
bien une idée de savoir la réponse à ça
je pense que c'est vrai mais que quelque
chose comme ça arriverait
c'était mon temps je mentionne plus très
bien mais voilà ça montre que des
questions qui sont finalement
relativement simple à dire les ce que
bon la légalité vois je l'exprimé de
sorte que ça peut paraître compliqué
tout mais quand même il était attirant
une ligne on veut dire mais c'est un
problème relativement simple qui me
paraît relativement intéressant on tient
en tant que prof de maths pur il se
trouve que à l'époque ça avait une
application les bons films en saas a pas
marché voilà c'est seulement que des
problèmes sur la loi des grands nombres
qui sont relativement simples sont
encore des problèmes ouverts grèce ce
problème dans mon cou de ma connaissance
c'est un problème encore ouvert donc
c'était un peu un troll se cuisent
puisque c'est une question va je suis
pas capable et a corrigé puisque je
connais pas la réponse mauvais m
et c'est un vrai ouvert j'aime bien
parler de ça parce que ça me semble
quand même qu'à des ventes pas si
sophistiqué de choses qui ont l'air bien
établie impression que la loi des grands
nombres
c'est un truc qu'on maîtrise sur le bout
des doigts on en parle tellement et tout
ça mais ban des variations pas pas si
farfelue de la loi des grands nombres
fait sont encore des problèmes ouverts
et sur lequel il encore de la recherche
à faire il a besoin de mieux comprendre
tout ça
c'est un côté frustrant mais c'est aussi
un côté génération il ya plein de
questions ouvertes il ya plein de choses
encore à découvrir
et voilà les problèmes assez simple pour
lesquels on peut être le premier à l'est
des îles et trouver aujourd'hui encore
car ma connaissance pour ce problème
bon voilà c'est certain ce n'est pas le
meilleur cuisent ses fruits désolé le
point de techniques vont pas aider moi
en tout cas pas juste parce que ça a
quand même plus et que on essaiera de
faire mieux la prochaine fois
moi sur ce bonne soirée et à bientôt